what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King Richie is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's video channel to
Jenny's podcast it's your boy The Fresh
Prince of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how can
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
if you're saying generation and that
likes the same things that you do go in
there having fun get out okay okay then
then get out then get um
I'm not here to get canceled today most
men want a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taking care of it yeah I'm ladylike I'm
submissive and you'd be surprised
because I will say I want to say now and
I'll say what I want to say with my mind
but my demeanor doesn't change and I'm
gonna look down on him because at the
end of the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened in
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so bad asking a
guy to buy like a three thousand dollar
bag now he's
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
um a couple announcements before we
start the show the first guys you
already know um we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
of those channels and also I'm just
pearly animations
um that is actually really funny this
guy does like animations of all my um
shows and clips and whatever so make
sure you go subscribe to that too also
guys we have four membership tiers not
one not two not three but four first
tier gets you to be a part of the chat
tonight which king what how many likes
to open up the chat
thousand five hundred a thousand five
hundred likes to open up the chat
tonight second year get to see my
Discord and my behind the scenes Vlogs
if you want to see me freestyle rap sign
up for the second tier third tier
connect with me on social media and
fourth here you get a one-on-one call
with me once a month you know I call
myself a YouTube genius and I think I've
earned that title so if you want to know
how to dominate YouTube get a million
subscribers in a year 1.5 million in a
year and a half make sure you go sign up
for that coaching call I will sit down
with you once a month and let you know
how to improve your YouTube channel
also guys they took away my first second
third fourth and fifth Tick Tock so make
sure you go follow my new one just
pearly things they also took away my
Instagram so make sure you go follow my
second one just purely things one also
go subscribe to wife school um we just
put out an episode of me kneading bread
so if you want to know how to need bread
go subscribe to that also quick question
Who here knows how to need Brad anybody
you do okay I was told this is common
knowledge in England everybody knows how
to do that and I just I think I was
being gaslit and I've done this for two
shows it's the real ones that we know
about needing especially when you're
starving at 2AM you get the flower out
get the yeast getting the soul out mix
it and let me give you the tip you need
to imagine that you're massaging
someone's back with bread kneading I
wasn't that good at it I I was improving
you know but it's my first time you know
you know first the hands are sticky yeah
once if you keep on mixing eventually it
just comes off I want to learn how to do
sourdough I love sourdough but yeah it
was harder than I thought I won't even
lie but
um also guys if you want to
um see our meetups where we have former
guests um from the show come we'll have
fans come we do meetups in London I'm at
usually just like a bar or something so
if you want to go to those make sure you
sign up for Google form so you will be
notified
um a lot of times we do them on short
notice I'm not the best planner so make
sure you sign up for a Google form and
put in your phone number and your email
also guys we are saving for a kickout
cam that I'm sure we're not going to
have to use tonight because everyone's
going to get along so
make sure um you donate for that how
many I think we need like I don't know
another thousand dollars to save up for
that so make sure you send donations for
the kickout cam
um also go subscribe to King Richie's
and Auntie Jenny our talents those
should be in the description sorry guys
those are all of our announcements so hi
guys welcome to the show
um so to start we're gonna do name age
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around
okay my name is Alicia I'm 24. I
um sorry I've forgotten all of the
things so name age relationship status
and then a fun fact about yourself
relationship status is single willingly
I'd like to think
um and a fun fact about myself is I'd
like to think that I have a good ear for
samples of old music in new music okay
what what type what kind
um I mostly listen to hip-hop or I'm
being rap but I know that there are a
lot of 80s 70s 60s samples in those so
I've got quite a good ear for that I'd
say do you have like a favorite 60s song
60s song I don't unfortunately I'm
really liking Gil Scott Heron at the
moment so I'd say sort of that it's
interesting to see how like the lyrics
have changed so much over time yes yeah
yeah yeah it's interesting because I
think music kind of reflects the culture
you know oh it absolutely does the state
of the people is the state of the music
right right um go ahead hello I'm Sophia
I'm 22 and a fun fact about me is I'm a
dancer and I'm from Australia okay cool
what kind of dance uh commercial oh I
don't know what I mean so like backup
kind of like modified hip-hop so like
backup dancing like music videos Type
style every time every time I think of
backup dancer I just think of a mirror
thing
it's an inside joke it's not like
nothing nothing to do with you oh my god
guys oh yeah I'm Natalie I'm 43 and a
fun fact about me is I'm vegan okay cool
how long have you been vegan three and a
half years
it's dedication I got really fat after
lockdown so that's dedication I could
never yeah go ahead hi my name is Pamela
and I'm 44 and I am a grandmother of
four wow girl you look good
how many girls how many boys I've got
three boys and one girl okay that's
awesome
I'm the notorious MLD I've been on the
show here all week basically right
um 37 years old recently single and fun
fact about me I'll be on the no jumper
podcast
soon oh cool yeah confirmed it you have
a date or have you are you telling
people to date I'm flying out on the 20
did they release the same day I'm I'm
filming everything on the 26th oh 26. uh
I think it's like a couple days they're
pretty quick though they're turn around
I think it's like two three days maybe
yeah so I'll be on there after this but
I'll be here until the 23rd on the just
Billy things cool cool
hello everyone my name is Sugar Puff
Puff on the outside and sweet in the
inside I am 31 years old and an
interesting fact about me is
I love just when I'm out in public I
love just seeing people and observing
them and if I see if they're sad or
upset or if they're struggling or if I
think they might suffer from loneliness
I'd go and talk to them sometimes I see
people dressed all nicely and you can
see that they're really hard workers so
if I think they've got a fly bag or
they've got a nice top or nice trainers
I compliment them I like to make people
feel happy
where was my compliment today
it's like 40 degrees outside bro that is
that is my style I do have a very plain
basic style that is I'm sorry no no no
I'm not offended I love you I'm not yeah
no you can't do this job and be offended
over that okay
um so today's topic we are talking about
body positivity
um so my first question is just a
general question
um do you think body positivity is a
good thing yes or no starting here and
then go around absolutely I think was it
body positivity benefits everyone and
it's an individual thing that you have
to cultivate within self and it
manifests for other people to perceive
positive win-win all round all right
what do you think I definitely agree and
I think that um
you need to be comfortable within your
own body as well and if you can be
positive and love yourself then you can
you know accept everybody else as well
okay
um I think it's a good thing maybe in a
way
um but then if you maybe look at the
health
side then maybe sometimes body
positivity might not be such a good
thing okay so
um what do you mean by that
um just
um you know I think that being body
confident you know you can come in you
can come in all sorts of different
shapes and sizes but if you're at a
point where
you might be at risk of certain health
issues then you have to bear that in
mind that's the subject that also needs
to be incorporated into that okay what
do you think um I think the word body
positivity can be used quite Loosely
um I think there's a lot behind it and I
think it's really about becoming a
better version of yourself and through
that there are many channels
so I I do believe in it and I believe
it's important uh for self-love okay
body positivity a good thing well I mean
when I look at body positivity I just
see a bunch of marketing directors
getting together and be like how can we
trick people into over consuming and
label it as something nice so
I'm a big proponent of having good
mental health and I think that you can't
have good mental health if you're
sitting around thinking of yourself in a
negative way and definitely in regards
to your body right you can't sit there
all day looking in the mirror and being
like I'm disgusting I'm this I'm that
because that's just gonna wreak havoc on
your psychological Health however I also
do believe that it is up to us
individuals because there are certain
biological components of life that are
irrefutably true in regards to
maintaining a healthy body weight and I
think that in my personal opinion
everybody should strive to be as best as
possible
a life of self-improvement and being
physically fit is one of many components
of that but I don't think I think the
body positivity thing is not this nice
thing that they're putting it out to be
I think there's a nefarious agenda
behind it which is just like yeah over
consume yeah you can do whatever you
want this kind of YOLO lifestyle but
people are starting to wake up to the
fact that like especially with the
recent you know situation that happened
in 2020 that we can't even talk about
without getting trouble here on YouTube
but I think a lot of people became more
health conscious about that at that time
so I think you know these corporations
corporations and governments they never
have your best interests at heart it's
always in the in their interest and
their interest is more power more
control directly over you so when I hear
body positivity like I get it you
shouldn't hate yourself like and men
have body positivity issues like men men
women they both look in America like
they want to be better than they are and
it's a struggle as a human but I do
think that
overall the body positivity movement I
think on the surface level it looks good
but I think behind it it's not what
they're saying it is
that's my short answer
the subject body positivity is actually
really personal to me because I'm
someone who I always like to treat
people nicely and I treat people well
and massage unfortunately always like
people would just be rude to me or
disrespect me I am 21 Stones now the
biggest I've been is 28 stones
and um I've had loads of like things
happen to me in my life
so
body positivity for me is just accepting
the way you look the way the way we were
made and
that's how I see body positivity you
know people have different definitions
some people think body positivity is
changing your body
um which is fine changing your body but
some people think that then like
basically they express how they're
unhappy with their body which is fine
but then um they say they're body
positive by changing their bodies but
for me it's just really literally
accepting yourself looking yourself in
the mirror and saying this is who I am
this is how I've been made this is how
people have seen me my whole life and if
they've been seeing me my whole life
like this I should just accept me and um
yeah I'm body positive okay so I'm just
raise of hands overall body positivity
good thing raise your hand
overall good thing like more good than
bad okay that's today and she's like
half okay okay so I I think body
positivity is a horrible thing I think
it's trying to normalize bad habits and
I don't think it's a good thing for
society
um so I want to know why you guys
disagree with that
because personally I just don't think I
don't think we would put a a crack
addict on the cover of a magazine in the
United States obesity is the number one
killer and I just don't think it's a
good thing that we are normalizing bad
habits that's my opinion on it it's
number one killer of pets too you know
that no way yep it's the number one
reason animals die in America is from
obesity but yeah you guys it's yeah go
ahead uh I think
um I get I see where you're coming from
I really do and it's sad and with most
things everything does become about
money for example I'll give you a
perfect example plus size women's it's
booming or the ever all the um plus size
influences are getting fat like they're
getting funding or they're being
invested in but with plus size men
there's been clothes that are being sold
for big men but the modules are small so
again I have a friend who did that where
she like they put on made her wear like
a fat fat suit where she was actually
smaller and they made her bigger yeah
they do well so for that reason yeah see
I see exactly where Pearl is coming from
because it upsets me that it is it has
become a money-making thing a kind of a
trend to kind of get get in the views
and getting that but for people who
actually have had issues and with me
honestly I will share my story one day
but I can't share it like until I reach
my goals and and I do and I think what
he is saying is spot on like they're
ready to roll out the red carpet for
women but it really it kind of again
goes back to like that kind of Nefarious
agenda of making money yeah you know
because they're catering to women
because like who can name some uh plus
size models right now like test holiday
for example a huge name right can any of
you name a male plus size model my
friend James Colby and he's a super
model but James Corbin is not
exclusively known for being an oversized
yes he's been invoked no no no no no but
he's known mainly for being a talk show
host no James Corbin is uh yeah
if it's James Bart oh okay he's a
plus-sized model he's from London and
he's someone who just um because he's a
plus size are you talking about the talk
show host James Corbin the guy who was
on the flight Scandal recently or no
so basically there's a plus size model
from the UK called James corbyn and he
talks about body positivity and um he's
making a difference for the plus size
community and he's not promoting obesity
I don't promote obce I tell people try
and stick to Natural Foods because you
may be big but at least if you're big
you're going to have goodness and you're
going to have a lot of like strength and
yeah because some people's bodies are
just the way they are Pearl you don't
know girl I I juice I even have a ninja
creamy like I make my own lime grapes
like all these things I actually care
about my health but my size I'm telling
you like
that doesn't make sense to me like I I
think if you did like a training plan
with me for a week you would lose weight
but I I really I really do like I think
you would so
um that's the thing because I have
medical issues as well I can't really
openly speak about but I have stuff like
gout flares that flares my hands up and
all that so there's always an obstacle
that comes in front but all my life I've
battled I've always said good food and
get out exercise never be that reason
don't ever let anyone give you that
reason to say you're fat and you're lazy
because that's the stereotype that the
world has of plus-sized people I think
there's something that we're not
addressing here
obesity and being plus size but really
it's obesity it's a clinical term it is
what it is it's a symptom of something
else well I agree with you if I were to
work out with you or with a personal
trainer I absolutely could lose the
weight and so could most other people
but obesity is a symptom of something
else she's right nine times out of ten
yes yes yes get someone in the gym put
them on a three-month training program
and say use this weight even if they do
lose it what's to stop them from putting
it back
so I'm saying shouldn't we fix that
problem then so if it's emotional let's
figure out what it is and fix it and
promote that instead of obesity on the
cover of Max she's spot on and the
number one way that people cope with
anxiety the most common way people cope
with anxieties by eating yeah exactly
you know you eat too much so yeah and
you're they're a thousand percent
correct that goes back to like you know
your subconscious uh mind and how you
perceive yourself because a lot of these
people too adding to what you said
they will lose the weight they'll lose
like 100 pounds 200 pounds 150 pounds
but the subconscious version of themself
in their mind is not that skinny healthy
person and they'll self-sabotage back up
to that weight so what she's saying is a
thousand percent correct it's not that I
mean I think
um people and I'm I'm from America like
where fat people were made and so
so like in America I think that the
American people are grossly
undereducated on the foundational
principles of having a diet carbs
proteins fats they don't even know that
those are the three different calorie
source and then alcohol if you want to
add that but and they don't know about
having high protein diet and managing
your calories and all that stuff but in
addition to that right because we grew
up in America thinking like cereal was a
healthy thing to eat as child which is
just sugar corded carbs right yeah now I
only eat that if I smoke weed in Miami
but you know the the she is a thousand
percent correct when she says it is
absolutely a symptom of some greater
problem that's occurring psychologically
because this is It's a manifestation of
something yeah but my point isn't like
that may be true but my point is we
shouldn't be promoting it for sure like
I just I have a problem when we start
putting that on the cover of magazines
because like a model is supposed to be
the epitome of beauty but it's supposed
to be like the top 10 15 of beauty just
like in the NBA you go to see the top 10
15 of NBA players and now we're putting
people that are overweight and unhealthy
on the covers of magazines and trying to
make it normal yeah and it's not like in
Asia that trend is not picking up and
they're like looking at America and
they're like what the are these
Americans doing well the average the
average woman in the U.S is five five
hundred seventy pounds it's overweight
yeah I know yeah and it's because
there's hyper there's high fructose corn
syrup in everything in America that's
the main reason there's literally high
fructose corn syrup and Seed oils and
everything that are just killing people
the chemicals do you okay my opinion is
I think people just need to be real
sorry 12.1 Stone if anyone so yeah 12
12.1 Stone what about Kayla's average uh
oh I thought Stone isn't that what you
guys do here I'm Australian so I think
77 and 78
77-78 yeah 77 kilo that was good you
didn't
know I live in Japan my skin
Japan yeah sorry go ahead
um I totally understand what you're
doing um what you guys are saying
um I just think people just need to be
more real especially plus size people
I'm not about the I'm not trying to lie
here I'm not trying to promote anything
but the truth is when for example when
you're shopping for clothes as a child
imagine from from four years old I was
always a bigger child and so I've always
I'm six foot clothes never fit me so um
so imagine so imagine now you're buying
clothes you're going shopping you want
to buy clothes still can't buy clothes
especially here so yes so for plus size
the way he is is they just they
basically just made anyhow in any cut so
you can get something and it will look
like you're wearing like blinds or
something or some sort of you've just
wrapped anything around you like that's
how he looks so that's why it's
important to have the representation but
I honestly think plus size people should
should just be real it is it is
unhealthy being big but what are you
doing about it I know what I'm doing I'm
eating properly I'm making sure I'm
having my green juice is I'm making sure
I'm having porridge so all the rubbish
comes out and and when I pig out I do
pig out and I love it but I just think
that's a bit like entitled to say oh
because I'm big now I need to see this
on the coverage I don't know maybe maybe
not you saying that but I'm just saying
like that that's what the body
positivity movement seems to be pushing
like we're big we need that
representation like I'm a ginger where's
my Ginger representation that's what
it's like I think we see which side like
I just think like models are supposed to
be the top like 10 of beauty like that's
supposed to be like I kind of want to
look at a magazine and see something I
will never attain
but Pearl that's the I'm I don't want to
say that's the that's not the right way
okay okay I go to the NBA I know I will
never be as good as those WNBA players
but it's okay because that's the top 10
of talent but that's the thing you're
your own self-pro just like you've got
this successful podcast that's you
that's what you're good at that's your
skill like people have their own things
that they're good at and and and we
should also celebrate as human beings
the stuff that we're good at our
individuality there's a there's it's
also a big difference between men and
women too because like metal watch like
predator and be like I bet you I could
figure out how to use steroids and like
look that good
a guy will think like I can I can up my
protein I can get a gym partner like you
know they they lead in their delusion in
a positive aspect but then like in from
my experience like you know if you were
to just
tell a woman that any part of her
physical appearance was maybe not up to
par according to your personal standards
as a man you know they take it as a
personal attack yeah and that's when
they're like well yeah well you have
fake teeth and your suit is ugly
you know so it's a big difference
between the genders for sure I I'm and I
just if you look at it right because
it's kind of disingenuous too if you're
intellectually sound enough to perceive
the reality of the situation that like
it's a it's a gigantic marketing
campaign towards women versus men
because if there was body positivity
we're talking about the entire body
correct like how many women often make
fun of guys who are short
it's like part of the culture like well
he's five foot five short man short man
short man syndrome small dick energy you
know the the the yeah imagine if guys
said small tit energy
like with girls my age like we all like
for my type right it's like tall you
need to be like minimum like five ten
yeah if I walk past someone that's like
five five for me I'm just like no sorry
instantly and nowadays
that's like that's not good for us girls
to like say that that is like a thing
but you don't see the men coming forward
and saying get short man on the cover of
magazines where's our short man
represents no you don't yeah and this
all goes back to money because it's all
about
and it's sad to say but
modern day marketing if you look at it
it is all geared towards financially
extorting women and you look at like for
example I'm American again I'm using
American example but over two-thirds of
the student loan debt in America is
owned by women and then on the flip side
of that the top 10 lowest earning
college degrees are all majority
dominated by women as well so they're
taking the tons of tons of debt and
getting the most worthless jobs and
they're later in life like yeah I want
to marry like they find out this guy is
amazing whatever they want to get
married she's like oh yeah but I have
like 150 000 student loan debt and the
guy's just like oh well you can be my
girlfriend
you know do you still have to pay that
off though yeah you have to
you have to that's and in America
sorry I'm American so I'm just giving
you guys American side of things that's
the only debt you cannot erase by filing
bankruptcy so you can file bankruptcy
like a credit card debt I've Mortgage
Debt car loans everything but you cannot
get rid of that loan to the United
States government well student loan debt
um so we have a video we're gonna show
could you show the couple one first
um okay I'm gonna read the super chats
really quick while we're waiting for him
to bring it up uh denalva it's so funny
they made an account denalva de Nava
denalva de Nava the actual corn industry
industry really sold up the public a
bill of goods uh sold us waste corn and
byproducts and surplus and cereal and
told us it was healthy
um all of those juices are full of sugar
that's not what you want a huge
contributor to the weight epidemic is
propaganda by the food industry sugar
and carbs in any form are going to be
stored as fat
um let me
one second guys also make sure you like
the video guys again just a reminder we
are going to open up the chat at
1500 likes
and then I just want to see how many it
was oh is it just the two okay I doubled
are you are you ready with it all right
interesting did she make that that's why
I wanted
that's actually it's funny because I'll
be like what the hell I've been going
unhealthy throughout the years that's
the thing there's a yes she's
celebrating herself but the way it's
done with happy music I'd be I'd be
actually no I can't say I kind of don't
want to say anything but I don't know
like I put on I was 28 stones
and one thing that I know I guess people
are different and it's good she's
celebrating herself but again that's the
type of I see how when skinnier people
skinnier than me look at this video I
can I can imagine what they think so I
know that you guys aren't also what do
you think they think they think oh gosh
she's dying she is her insides are
growing older and and I'm not gonna lie
same with me when and I'm when I'm
eating certain things I'm thinking oh
gosh oh gosh like something and you know
with big people as well like yeah let me
give some big plus-sized facts when you
have to go to the Loo I'm telling you it
feels like fireworks are out in your
belly and and there is a pressure so but
like all these plus size okay sorry I
think I'm going up yeah sorry guys sorry
the thing is this for me like so I'm a
big fan of love I'm a big fan of like
being in love and being in a
relationship having a good woman in your
life and for me like I just maybe this
is selfish babe like you need to
stay skinny so you don't die because I
don't want to do this again I don't want
to fall in love and lose you and all
that so anytime I'm in a
relationship with a girl whether she
works out or not she's gonna start
working out when she's dating me so I
would just hate to see that as a person
dating someone who is gaining weight and
then I have to be like looking and
dealing with the health issues and come
with that yeah so women are more likely
than men to gain weight after marriage
so do you guys think it's fair to gain
weight after getting married why not I
don't think it's I don't think so either
you don't think it's fair drop it on
them drop it on them
I haven't met you a certain way and
I believe that's what they went for and
that's what they desired so that's what
they will continue to desire and
although they would probably still love
you they definitely wouldn't find you
still as attractive that's just that's
just how it would be yeah I think that's
just like a lot of I think that's like
really common sense that's really not
present in today's generation because
it's just like it's unfair it's so
selfish to just like that's like a guy
getting a relationship with a girl like
oh you know what
I'm gonna quit my job and I want you to
take care of me next question
you guys encourage your partners just
encourage them with food encourage them
exercise why do we have like for example
yeah but he probably was encouraging her
but she she literally gained 120 pounds
that's a whole other human they did it
together it feels it seems like they it
was their couple goal it was like you
know
they did it she got bigger you didn't
get that much bigger yeah we played
again
you guys don't know the world of top
Chasers as well I'm I am big so I can
tell you the world of top Chasers but
we're talking about the video like the
keywords
speak women no no come on he wouldn't
admit then he wouldn't have married wait
wait wait wait he would have married a
big woman if he wanted a big woman so I
think it's one thing if you marry wait
if you marry a chick and she's like over
I don't know what 200 pounds is here
okay that's one thing but it's like if
you sign up for one thing and then she
bamboozles you later you think that's
fair just like if I marry a guy thinking
he's gonna pay all the bills and I'm
gonna get to be a stay-at-home wife and
that's what I thought and then one day
he's like you know what
yeah I just don't feel like working
anymore
I don't feel like being faithful anymore
I'm just gonna go every girl I can
find now or on her side too would just
not be cool I just think that you need
to be
because I think it's common sense when
you get a relationship you're like okay
this is what I like so let's try to keep
this going or make this better right and
if it goes both ways yeah and I think
that I've I've been there I've been in a
relationship and I've put on weight in
that relationship so I'm not just
talking you know blindly I've
gone up to 16 stone at my heaviest
so but I also know that as much as you
try to put this body positivity on
everything at the predict at that
particular point in my life I was very
unhappy
through a lot of reasons because I knew
that I wasn't the same person I was when
my partner met me and I didn't feel
confident in myself but even though I've
lost that weight I've still carried that
with me so for the Americans at home I
was calculating yeah 16 stone is 224
pounds
you're 220 pounds 59 like nearly 16
Stone
so wow seriously I know how I fit so as
much as people used to say oh you look
good me personally for myself I didn't
feel that way
so I I was like that my whole life but I
I was just sick and tired of being
unhappy I'm like do you know this world
is so short yeah and if you can get to
that point without that then great bar
me personally it was just a massive
thing I couldn't get past it it's
amazing
because a lot of the majority of people
it look they when they get that big they
can't go back it's a large percentage of
people that well
yeah I was at my heaviest I was 19 Stone
that's more than 16 Stone
wow are you guys friends yeah yeah you
guys meet each other you guys do it
together yeah did you lose it together
no I I was literally the the fat kid
that ate cake I was the food was my
comfort it was it was everything like
Matilda yeah and that's that's all I
loved and it was an everyday thing but
in my head in my mind I was Shifting the
weight but the reality of it as I wasn't
I wasn't motivated and there was nothing
to work toward and I lived with that for
most of my childhood I lived with that
throughout my early adult years
um I I had children when I was young so
obviously after having children
um you've got the baby weight that
stayed on you and then you will have
areas of your body then that
um that you can't cover up yeah you know
that you can't hide
um and so that kind of led me to then
staying at home home and then there's a
cycle after that
um where you know you're at home you're
socially excluded from from from places
and people and then you tend to put
yourself into a box or a self-hate then
um because whatever trauma that you
actually had which got you there starts
to manifest as you get older and when
you look at the people around you and
you look at how people respond to you
um you're constantly battling yourself
and it is self
um and and for me I had to heal first I
had to First figure out what was the
trauma yeah where's the problem
um and with that you don't even know
where to begin because you don't know
what the problem is and then you have to
Soul search you have to look who you've
got around you you then have to look at
your parents
um how you grew up your school days
um and all of that you have to calculate
and sometimes you are the problem
sometimes the way that you've behaved is
a problem however the way that you've
behaved isn't necessarily because you've
wanted to be that way but you was trying
to be something that you was not in the
first instance so for me once I
discovered all of that
um and I and I shifted to to some weight
and got to a healthy weight I then chose
for me to have surgery that was that was
the gift to myself
so after I'd healed and I'd recognize
where the trauma came from and I dealt
with that trauma my gift to myself then
was to have surgery what kind of surgery
I had a tummy tuck good for you I've had
liposuction me too I've had my boobs
done I I had I had like what so I did so
and tying into the whole thing because a
lot of people try to like on me
right now because I got liposuction
right because I was just in such a bad
place you know why because I was reading
YouTube comments
everybody's just telling me this wasn't
like 2021 March I got it but I also was
fully transparent about it and I made a
full documentary oh good about it in
Tokyo and but at the time it was so
crazy because I was so like just
constantly being slammed because I
wasn't like huge I just had like a
little in the in my midsection and then
I was just like a man possessed and then
I just like yeah let's do it let's do it
pay pay pay whatever and then next thing
you know I'm laying on the
surgery tail I'm like oh like this
is gonna be crazy and then I woke up and
I was just like oh my God I can't
believe I went through with that that
you know it's the same for myself but
and you know it's you know it's so crazy
too given that because like I said I'm
not I'm not hiding it I don't care I I
tell everybody you know what put it on
my Tombstone like put it right there
here lies MLD you got liposuction what
an
you know um
happy when I did it and then I learned a
lot of lessons along the way
so but even though now I get shamed why
for being a man that got liposuction
right but I don't care because you get
called lazy though that you were lazy oh
you everything this guy does this guy
has no discipline this guy this this guy
that I'm like have you seen the
business Empire that I run like I didn't
run that being lazy but all that aside
yeah I would rather personally I would
rather be shamed for getting liposuction
than being shamed for being overweight
and at this point in my life if they
because people are going to criticize
you no matter what and I did use it
because you know I wanted to create this
documentary
and one of the fat cells out of my body
and so
um I'm still I'm even here on the UK on
my trip I'm still exercising I still eat
clean yeah and I understand to uh is it
Alicia Alicia Alicia Alicia I'm so sorry
I'm okay you'll forget her Malaysia as
Alicia alluded to earlier Alicia was
correct when she said the symptom is
something going on inside you and then
Pam as well said that what was going on
inside of you is there is some there's
some trauma there's some things so I
think what Pearl said is absolutely
correct we can't glorify this because at
the end of the day what we're doing is
we're glorifying poor mental health yes
because it's we can't be glorifying that
kind of stuff because and you're
literally sending people off to an early
grave I'm a big fan of being alive
you know and it's so it's interesting
too that you guys like weren't hand
selected for this body positivity thing
I know I have no idea yeah that's like
the universe is coming together that's
pretty cool the the thing is there's a
perception
um when it comes to people that choose
to have elective surgery and that is
what I try in my day-to-day life try to
allow people to see that it's not about
just wanting to have surgery to get rid
but some people are are not best gym
candidates I wasn't I mean I I'd spent
thousands of pounds on on personal
trainers on diet plans
um I was doing all sorts however what
happens is yes you might lose the weight
the weight will go down in my case I I
had a hernia I'd had three C-sections
um my stomach was protruding that's the
the reptile muscle in the middle was had
opened I needed to have muscle repair
and that cannot be fixed in the gym
right so when I was losing the weight in
fact I actually looked better when I was
bigger because I could hold my own when
I lost the weight everything dropped and
went down south yeah it looked worse
yeah to be fair
um so when I saw that it happened after
I'd lost all the weight well what do I
do now because the gym is not going to
help this yeah I need to have a tummy
tuck yeah I need to have muscle repair
so so knowing that I needed to have that
done there is there is a you know a
number of people out there why don't you
go to the gym well I did yeah for many
years and my biggest thing is too if
we're supposed to like enthusiastically
support people chopping off their
wieners and becoming women like you've
got to shut up about this other stuff
too like guys can I say something to
someone you know you gotta choose one
can I share something please can I just
remind you all that body positivity
isn't only like people with big big
black relatives it's about unable people
as well and people are born deformed
some people are born with disabilities
and I think body positivity is also
linked with that but the main the main
marketing component of body positivity
is towards women to say you can be obese
I just don't think we should celebrate
something that's a choice
you're celebrating it when you're
putting on the cover of magazines that's
a reward that's like a positive thing
when you're you're specifically giving
people Parts because they're plus size
when you're specifically trying to put
it out there make that the
representation of in the media
um and and it's interesting too because
earlier you said like um that you seem
to say like you couldn't lose the weight
was that what you were saying earlier
yes I couldn't but it's but it's like
before we the podcast starts
no don't get me wrong yeah
um hello I'm on your podcast I want to
have a good time you know I'm not at
home I don't need to be freaking old
healthy stuff but what I'm saying Okay
the reason I say that is just because
I'll hear people say that but then I
like watch what they eat and I'm like it
doesn't seem to know do you know it's
just about representation it's it's
basically the little things from like
there's for example you can go to a
store you can't get certain things
um you can order something from online
you can't see you can't actually because
there's not the person wearing it you
can't see it
I was actually going to say something
what I wanted to say is
um it's actually just gone go on take it
away I think just the man thoughts just
escaped that's fine I think
it all starts as well from a young age
and how you're brought up yes and the
way that your parents feed you and what
they do for you being brought up well
and that's why I think it's so important
to like get in control of your eating
habits if you want to have children
because it's not fair to the Next
Generation to be brought up with eating
habits that will give you an early grave
and I even think about that with myself
because I have like a horrible sugar
addiction I literally love sugar it's so
bad so does everybody else yeah it's
addictive right but we do have like
health problems because like a lot of
people in my family eat a lot of I
forget what the early onset something I
don't remember okay person but but like
I think of this even for myself you know
yeah so I think it's like important that
we don't celebrate that sort of thing
yeah I agree with that because growing
up for me I used to see my mum forever
doing different diets yeah going on the
Cambridge diet you know when you just
eat the shakes and you have those
cardboard bars you know the keto diet as
well
my mum do that and I remember being at
school and my mum was happy to say let
mum I want to go on a diet and she'd
pack my rivita with my fruit and I was I
was at school at year eight year nine so
12 13. and my mum was happy to do that
whereas
you know it's it's it's created bad
habits for me and yeah I think habits
everything in moderation do you know
what I realized too I think it's um a
problem that comes from moms not being
in the home anymore yeah because when
moms are in the home they're watching
like what everyone's eating and like
they're full it's tough to do that to
watch but everyone's eating when you're
you're working like 20 30. in addition
to that too in addition to that these a
lot of these food companies are behind
the body body positivity movement
because they know that their food is not
really food it's like legislative poison
yeah they have so much high fructose
corn chemicals and then in addition to
that too the rates of home cooking is
going down all across the globe guilty
yeah and then you know people want to
order ubereats and this and all that
crap and then you're just eating
processed food and I personally this is
me I'm not well I don't have a food
degree or whatever my degree is in
Psychology but I do believe that the
rise that we're seeing we're ever seeing
an increasing rate of cancer in people I
think that's directly correlated to the
amount of processed food that we're
consuming yeah this is what I wanted to
say earlier body positivity is important
and the reason why it's important is
because people have grown grown up but
watching different things they've
watched a certain type of people they've
watched a certain type of behavior
and people there are some people that
don't leave their house there are some
people who travel there are some people
who don't experience much
and they don't know they they judge
people they have certain behaviors what
what's taught on telly and that's why
it's important it's not because it's
important like big people should be
promoted is important because
some people actually aren't nice and
some people do judge and some people
speak use a certain language and if
there was while growing up if there was
a mixture of people if there were a
mixture of cultures mixtures of
backgrounds all these things
but again
body positivity wouldn't be needed but
unfortunately we've been programmed to
think this is beautiful that is
beautiful
no no because no if you try if you if
you look at because they did a study on
this is what I do for a living yeah so
let me just tell you so they did a study
on female attractiveness across all
cultures also over multiple different
generations and time periods and what
guys like is still the same all hips
nice butt big breasts
I have something here too it says
um obese women are 20 less likely to
marry um this is a survey of over 10 000
people which is a huge sample size
according to a large 2022 Social Survey
on dating dating 65 percent of men would
would assign a rejection score to three
out of five women meaning they would
they're more likely to reject them and
18 of men assign a five out of five
rejection score meaning they would
definitely reject them so on that I'd
like to point out that we are talking
about obese people because fatness is
seen as the monolith of body positivity
and fat people are an easy target we can
have skinny people on the covers of
magazines and no one will say anything
you won't hear repeat yeah
no they did in the early 2000s they said
the girls were too scary skinny I
actually remember that yeah no they
definitely did
anorexia was literally a thing models
were yeah they were demonizing and
that's the casting director were getting
sued also yeah that's what I'm saying
people complained um the skinny girls
aren't on the covers anymore they're
replaced you think they're being
replaced by fat people yes
that's not true I'm sorry let's look at
let's look at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show that was like the epitome
of modeling yeah
Victoria that was one of the the top
like the epitome you cannot tell me and
then that that was not one of the most
competitive like everyone wanted to be a
victim and then since they've switched
to Victoria's Secret has been bleeding
money they're losing money right now
they're no longer a profitable business
you need to think about how these brands
are moving as well with Victoria's
Secret it was this tall woman there's
this blonde hair yeah she's she's a
certain looking type and you really see
a difference
um in what Rihanna's doing she's
involving a whole load of range and
she's getting themselves so Victoria's
Secret didn't move with the time and
another friend is taking over I mean I
don't think we should have to adjust
because of people's choices like I don't
like because if you make a choice to be
overweight like why does society have to
adjust to you like why does there have
to be representation wait let me finish
why does there have to be representation
on the cover of magazines why do they
have to make specific stores for bigger
people when really we should be focusing
on losing the weight but imagine for you
as a tall person I used to be I used to
be pretty big yeah so your tools so
I'm sorry I just I keep on losing my
thoughts sorry your tour and imagine you
going to look I'm guessing loads of
places you go and you're like oh gosh
I'm tall I can't actually I can't
include myself in that just like with
plus size people now some people are
lazy no it's not fair though but some
people are some people are lazy and I
have to pay extra money but I live you
know yeah
it's like but that's the thing some
people have a choice of being big some
people are ill and they're big there are
different types of reasons why people
are big some people well no personally
and I'll put this on the podcast anyone
says that they have no choice in being
big I'll pay for their personal training
and their nutrition I'll pay for it
myself
okay if I want to lose weight can I get
in touch with you foreign
[Laughter]
but then look there's certain laws of
physics too that are like like you can't
just spontaneously get fat like the only
way you get fat is from over consuming
calories there's no hands ifs or butts
about it my mom just came to Tokyo and I
told her to get you I'm gonna take care
of you but you got to be on fat camp
because I want my mom around right and
so I brought her over and I had to teach
her the fundamentals of losing weight
fasting physical fitness training muscle
training and all these things right she
was grossly grossly undereducated on
these things and in three months
she lost 25 pounds I sent her back home
right
so but you know what you told me before
she came
to Tokyo she's like well I have been
going through menopause that's why I'm
gaining weight I was like Mom I love you
but that is
literally impossible yeah for you just
to spontaneously create fat cells it
doesn't work like that like it is
understanding your daily calorie needs
and then if you over consume those daily
calorie needs your body will convert the
remainder of food into fat and there is
no and Zips or butts about it so
I'm not saying I understand what you're
saying like being fat isn't choice but
because I think people are just
undereducated because when you do over
consume food because a lot of people
like you know when you when I see these
girls drinking these like venti size
Starbucks with like
800.00
one drink is like 800 calories that's
like that's a good rib eye steak
okay mine's 300.
honestly this whole obesity thing and
look at the what the food industry is
doing look at the policies and
procedures that are changing no it's
like a lot of food remember a lot of
obesity starts because people are are
reacting with what's in our food that's
not actually good for US Air fryers they
they're having they're having causes
I'm sorry but with the internet there's
just no excuse you can look into all of
this stuff you know like we can't blame
the food and just get it like that you
know I still drink my I've been trying
to lose 15 pounds forever but I still
drink my Starbucks every day it's my own
damn fault we had pizza last night
I tried to cook something I didn't I
didn't eat breakfast or lunch today
because we have pizza
and some people maybe cannot only offer
Dollar Store food you don't know
eggs are cheap ground beef is cheap like
chicken the cheap one is cheap big I
mean because it's got stuff in it but if
you want to get an organic one oatmeal
is cheap no I mean there's not no
there's really but you'd be surprised
how many stuff is in our meat in our
chicken I did this I actually have an
episode on wife's school if you want to
watch it like um Auntie got me 50 pounds
for two weeks of groceries all organic
foods so if you guys do want to learn
about it it's on wife's school you can
do it though
I think it was maybe stop this year it
will last year I was literally went
grocery shopping
and I went to obviously like Audi or
something like that right luxury
you know it's cheap but like you can get
good you know healthy foods there
and I was like I was vegetarian for nine
months I did live with the Indian family
at the time as well so like it helped me
I was at that time
literally 10 kilograms heavier than I am
now and when I went vegetarian for nine
months I'd have like meat every so often
um when I was at my ex-boyfriend's now
house but like
just cutting out the meat for me
all that time helped me actually lose
that weight but also compared to
Australia and here your food here goes
off so much quicker which is a good
thing yeah and in Australia I it can be
my fridge for like two months a month
and it's still I can still eat it yeah
it doesn't last more than three days
here the best kind of food expires in
like five days and after five days
you're like which is good like I live in
Japan like the the Japanese wives they
go to the grocery store every day yeah
because it does go off quickly yeah the
do you know what the world is going to
get fat and fat I should tell you why
why because you know a lot of these
vegan foods these processed sausages and
all that and they're things to be good
you need to see what's actually in them
they they're actually they're gonna they
they actually they're not processed they
actually the marketing thing it's
another agenda yeah so all this vegan
food everything else is still gonna
carry on the Obesity in us because what
they're putting in it's it's not great
and that's the truth and that's why I
say anyone who wants to be lose weight
since this is a plus size topic eat
Natural Foods your vegetable try and go
as organic as you can and just think
about green what's good what's what what
can you take from the earth that's been
provided naturally that's my advice I
would say walk go for walks just I just
wanted to say like when like we were
going on the um topic of like front of
magazines and stuff like that the covers
of magazines do you not also think that
this whole you know 10 Perfect Image can
also have a detrimental effect mentally
women because we are going to strive to
want to be that 10 so that's going to
then create a whole that was funny
I have an answer only if you're mentally
weak
I want my self-esteem to be a little bit
humbled and lowered when I look on the
covers I remember the days when I I
could pull the cover off and put it on
my fridge and she was my motivation yeah
I liked those days
that's a good thing
it does create more issues for those
people who have the trauma well and I
also think it's okay to be an average
chick like why do we live in this world
where you need to be top 10 people
but there's a new average if people are
growing more corpulent and obesity is
becoming the norm then the average is
actually changing and what I wondered
right well
I didn't say lowered or elevated because
I think that's quite subjective we're
talking about beauty we're talking about
health health I don't think it's Beauty
and beauty isn't subjective men find
genuine generally the same things
attractive and what cultures and at what
time periods if we read up on it across
cultures you could see that in history
being on the heavier side was actually a
sign of being wealthy that is true I've
done it
we've had so many people bring this up
on the shows it's not true not across
the board yeah they they want coaches is
it not true it goes back to like it goes
back to like Mesopotamia and are we
talking about so when I say it was a
sign of being wealthy or Rich we're
talking about people not having enough
money and therefore starving and being
on the gaunter side of of the spectrum
right versus people who are wealthy and
obviously when you have money you're you
know your discipline decreases and so
you're spending on food and you grow to
be more corpulent and so what I'm trying
to say is like there have been multiple
time periods multiple cultures where
they studied multiple fertility guards
and goddesses of sex and they all were
the same they were a big nice round but
small hips big breasts flat stomach okay
young yes right and that's literally
multiple time periods over multiple
cultures that couldn't even communicate
with each other so we talked about Asia
Africa you know the Aztecs all of these
Europe they have all of these things and
it's correlating across all of these
cultures during all these time periods
so it's it is an objective marker and
then if you look at now too like despite
this gigantic corporate push towards
body positivity
dudes still like skinny hot girls big
boobs okay and those same women who are
the personification of Beauty for men
how do we know that they are not equally
unhealthy as someone who is perhaps my
shape who is a little bit on the on the
rounder side and people might look at me
and have health concerns yes like let's
talk about the difference the disparity
between how someone presents and what is
going on on the inside because this
discussion it transcends health and
beauty we're talking about I'll give you
two things one is a lot more common so
the Obesity is a much more common than
anorexia only like yeah I don't know the
exact number but it's less than five
percent of women are even underweight so
one is much more common and the second
thing is um morbidly obese people's life
expectancy drops so by by mult I don't I
don't know the exact number off the top
of my head so when you look at the
numbers of the people that are underway
and the people that are morbidly obese
the people that are morbidly obese have
a lower life expectancy yeah like these
processes these style model these plus
size models are starting to drop off
there was this Latina plus size model
she was 37 years old she died from heart
heart attack and the number one reason
people die in the world is due to
circulatory issues and once you're obese
and you're consuming too much food your
veins and everything they actually get
uh clogged up with excess amounts of fat
when you're a skinny person that's just
I mean biologically it's impossible
because you don't have an exodus amount
of fat so when you talk about markers of
Health that's what I'm trying to say is
like the larger girls that one marker of
Health in regards to circulatory health
is going to be lower compared to
somebody who is thinner and we're
talking about that one specific
molecular of Health well do you know do
you know which uh which people live the
longest on the planet what Enlighten us
isn't it isn't it Mediterranean nope
Japanese women oh no way Japan has the
third lowest obesity rate in the world
you know as a direct correlation to that
does that tell you why why because they
eat their own food and they ain't eating
no processed foods they stuck to their
rice yeah they stuck to their steamed
fish they stuck to all the Natural Foods
that's why because they kept it not they
kept it good but with I think with the
western food in general a lot of it is
processed that that is the issue a lot
of other money and it's quick accessible
quick and easy accessible like when
people sit around they people sit around
and they eat carbs and they think like
I'm just eating carbs like I'm because I
feel hungry but they keep eating it and
then they wonder why they keep feeling
hungry is because they're not getting
satiated they're not getting the
vitamins they need they're not getting
the nutrients the micronutrients all
these things so like I noticed
personally that when I switched to just
eating two grass-fed grass-finished
steaks a day like I would be completely
satiated but I mean when was last time
you're eating potato chips and you're
like I've had enough potato chips
you know just slamming them down yeah
let's talk about your cholesterol
because aren't there some schools of
thought that say if you over index on
red meat that your cholesterol goes
through the roof yes and butter though
as well potentially I actually had a
woman that only eats red meat yeah
does she look good she had really um
clear skin and all of hero like
autoimmune issues went away like she had
like a bunch of health problems things
all went away by eating I don't know
it's all down to the meat industry where
does she get her meat we don't know she
probably gets good meat and if she has a
heart attack tomorrow what do we what do
we say to that then it probably didn't
work like but so far she hasn't had a
heart attack but then there are loads of
uh sort of plus-sized people myself I
haven't had a heart attack yet and I'm
I'm like my BMI is terrible I haven't
had a heart attack and I can still stand
for an hour only you're only four you're
only 24 though it's like I've talked to
people like your size roughly and
they'll say like after like 30 that's
when they really really start to get
healthy yes girl it really comes in like
honestly as soon as you hit 30 I'm
telling you I I wish I prepared
personally so my advice is before you
reach 30 just start stretching
stretching is one thing I wish I did
more of and now I'm learning that it's
in the hard way but now that I've got
myself into practice it's just so much
easier about stretching I just think too
as a culture people like just eat too
much in general people when they're I
mean did you guys eat when you were
bored yes yeah I would eat for five all
the time
I'd be sitting at home and I'd be like
Oh I'm bored let me just go to the
pantry and find something oh there's
nothing there oh okay I looked at the
health effects of being over obese and
then it's at all causes of death so it's
like high blood pressure high out high
cholesterol low cholesterol type 2
diabetes coronary heart disease Strokes
gallbladder
um
osteoarthritis sleep apnea low quality
mental illness such as clinical
depression anxiety and other mental
disorders body pain and so it's like I
just think it's like we wouldn't put
someone that like that's a CR my cousin
use a heroin addict and I we wouldn't
put heroin addicts on the covers of
magazines but more people are kill or
die from obesity related you know how
many people die from obesity every day
400 people die every day you know how
many people died in September 11th how
many just 500 no just over 3 000.
you know so you're having like I was on
Brandon Carter's show and he was telling
me this so he says like every three days
you're having September 11th in in
Modern Life so you know it like yeah I
think it's just it's UNF because nobody
wants to be called fat nobody wants to
be told you're ugly nobody wants to be
sexually unattractive men or a woman we
all want to be hot we all want to be
sexy you know we want to be good looking
it doesn't that never leaves you and so
when you're confronted with an
uncomfortable reality most people and
it's sad to say but most people can't
handle the truth yeah and so they choose
a nice little lie that makes them feel
better and that's why Oprah has money
that's why the view has money that's
what Dr Oz has money that's what Dr Phil
has money sit down down and a lot of
women come on down you know and so
sometimes it's like I think harsh truths
that time can make you make life changes
yeah like like I I was I was pretty
heavy at one point and what made me like
200 Club yeah
what was the highest that you've got
like like 210 maybe 215 yeah
I don't know what that is like 90 92 93
kilos yeah I saw a picture of myself no
that was parsley too Natalie that
happened to me I'll show you the picture
[Laughter]
so I played I played volleyball my whole
life so I was training like five hours a
day from the time I was like I don't
know 10 years old so I was just an
athlete and when I stopped playing my
eating habits were horrible like
absolutely horrible so I gained weight
like really really fast because I just
couldn't burn off all the calories I was
burning before and I was working a sales
job and there was a guy I had a crush on
at work I had the biggest crush on the
skies and I heard I heard him laughing
with um the other guys at work saying oh
like the the one guy was like oh I'm
like 190 or something and he's like you
can't be that big that's so that's so
heavy I would never like and then they
were talking about girls and they're
like I would never date a girl over 200
and I was like they didn't think I was
that big because I'm tall so I carry it
a bit better yeah but really but that
but that harsh truth like I lost a bunch
of weight after that and I've kept it
off ever since yeah so you know
sometimes you need that kick don't you
just to make you realize yeah and like
you know it might have been harsh at
first but it was true true yeah if we're
talking about self-esteem doesn't you
mention being weak-minded earlier
hearing your crush or people that you
might fancy and and realizing that your
type doesn't like you back does that not
make you weak-minded then if self-esteem
is really in self and you're hearing
people you find desirable talk about you
in an undesirable way and you're saying
that made you change even though the
change was for the positive let's say
does that not make you weak of mine
because I think it makes you taste
strong because I made me do something
strong I ran a marathon because I was
like you know if those were the type of
guys I want to date this is what they
want and the difference is women have
never heard what men want but men always
change to try to get us like they try to
make more money they try to get in
better safe they take steroids
and it's like we have never heard what
men want yeah like ever because the
media is constantly telling us what we
want to hear so no I I don't think it
makes me a weak person I think I could
have it would have been weak to go and
cry but I went and did something about
it yeah but taking on someone's opinion
and letting that influence your
lifestyle and your actions is not weak I
I don't think it's a bad thing to be
maybe it's not an opinion I mean I mean
it's a it's a fact yeah I think I think
because then you you kind of fall into
the school of thoughts like you know
because like if you're getting fired
from job after job after job you'll be
like well these people have a poor
opinion of me like but that's what's can
I just say something that's what's
that's what's wrong with the world
people people care too much
I think people don't care like you said
earlier I think we should care about
outcomes especially as women because
it's like if we don't in our 20s in like
early 30s get our together like we
don't get to have children but and so
it's like like one obesity affects
effects if you get to have kids and two
it affects the type of husband you you
get because geriatric pregnancy starts
at 35. don't ever assume big people
can't there's honestly likely to kiss
I'm not even gonna I feel ugly most of
my life but when I went nuts bridge I'm
not gonna I learned the power of being
big all these people from UAE they'll be
beeping the car so they'd be saying
hello there's numbers on this at least
for women I I don't research it as much
for men but like I research it more for
women like men that don't make as much
money tend to date bigger but like it's
really yeah wow because they get free
food probably no
there's a guy with money
the girl someone who has a preference
yeah
but I'm saying I'm saying nobody the
guys that have all the options Nobody
Does it just like a beautiful woman is
never going to pick a broke man in the
same way
the top 10 15 no no it's not agree it's
like if we look at the men that have
everything the most desired men in
society they don't typically pick big
girls the same way the most desired
women in society don't typically pick
broke men yeah just like I've actually
got I want to hear what Pam disagrees I
want to hear what because it's it falls
down to to your preference what you
actually like but you like it so if you
know yourself
and you know what you like whether that
person has money or not it wouldn't even
matter yeah just like it from women to
men or men what are you talking from
women selecting from my perspective from
women to men so if you don't have any
money or you need a bit of help but I
like you anyway I'm gonna like you who
you are yeah I've Got a Theory by the
way guys can I share my theory data it
just doesn't like it's really nice when
we can say this and maybe that applies
to you but at large it just doesn't like
women when women get a promotion at work
they're more likely to divorce their
husbands
really why I think people are crazy I
think the world's gone mad my theory is
okay people who have come up to me like
a lot of people have come up to me and I
don't know but once I asked one of them
how long were you breastfeed for and
they replied saying oh I'll be older and
I realized everyone that lacks big
people yeah
they've been rested for long and or
their mom or they are they had a big
Auntie or a big mom so and they're used
to like that sort of feeling so as an
older adult that's what they seek and
that's the truth and it's unfortunately
it's a cycle I don't know if it's also
unfortunate but it is a cycle I mean fat
fat people raise fat children because
they passed you you pass your ways you
know but sometimes the parents that's
why rich people typically their children
are also rich but because they pass on
the knowledge of things but sometimes I
know families I know families where the
parents are like twigs and the kids are
like Monsters I literally and I don't
mean that in a bad way but compared to
the parents
this is an open invite look at anybody
that thinks they cannot lose weight for
whatever reason it's impossible okay
I'll pay for it come come to London
Ethan Klein come on down
you
be careful what you say because there
might be a lot of big people that start
messaging you
okay okay first first two first two
limited you know
can I say something dude yeah yeah
um I just wanted to
um touch on the point of food the
reality is it doesn't really matter what
you eat processed foods
healthy foods the reality is the science
is clear if you eat more calories than
your body can can convert to energy
you're gonna get fat yeah it does that's
irrefutable that's not I don't believe
in that I'll tell you what I mean it
looks it looks like it doesn't blame
it's true I'll give you my anecdotal
experience oh great for the most part of
my life I have I have been eating
unhealthy like I don't eat healthy the
only times I really ate healthy was when
I was young but for most of my adult
years
I don't have time to cook I don't have
time to do all of that but I eat once a
day
[Music]
I don't know if anyone here is repeating
the science does anyone here disagree
that the more calories you consume and
you don't exercise
yeah we all agree I think sugar pop said
he disagreed okay
you can't put calories on a on a leaf
you can't put calories on spinach you
can't do this you just eat it goes from
the ground that's when I think with all
this calorie counting and stuff like
that how do you actually calorie count a
carrot because each carrot is different
or each other
and also did you know calories
you know food calories when they say on
the label like whatever calories it is
did you know each person consumed in
their body when they consume food the
calories change and it's different for
each person it then boils down to your
metabolism yeah but you can do a
metabolism like my other point is this
is that we can all fit like this is
something that can be fixed
and that's the great thing about like
women most of the things that men want
can be fixed like men want fit feminine
friendly women those are all things that
can be fixed we're faithful yes
but on the other hand it's like men they
can't make themselves taller no but they
don't complain near as much as we do
about men's preferences we can we are
Our Own Worst Enemy to be fair yeah um
[Laughter]
a woman speaking the truth bam
and then we tried to as a woman we tried
to look for a solution and sometimes
that solution
um I mean my job is I take women for
surgery I take them to Turkey I take
them to the Dominican Republic
um they come to me we sit down we look
at the mental health issues surrounding
that
um and then I provide them with their
post-operative care so so yeah it's
amazing I've recently been shut down by
Instagram myself as well so I know what
that's like
but we have a generation now of women
today who
um they're they're using some of them
that all are using surgery as a as a as
a woman as a way to lose weight as a
quick fix and they're not getting
healthy
um and you've got clinics now
um that are easily accessible the price
is now great and and they're going for
surgery and they're having these
surgeries and they're coming home and
they're coming home with issues yeah so
so I've been dedicated and I've and I
have a passion making sure that that
women are are fully informed as to what
they are doing why they are doing that
and to understand the processes that
happen afterwards yeah but we have a
problem we have a real real issue
especially here in the UK
um where women are dying yeah because of
it
and there's you know because
um after I got so for men do you know
about what happens to men after you get
liposuction no tell me so so your penis
swells up
that happens to the vagina
no no because here's the thing the the
the the the all the fluids and
everything gravity dry you know it let's
go towards it it drops down there yeah
but I guarantee your vagina didn't look
like a huge purple eggplant my vagina
it was huge and nobody told me me
neither me neither I had surgery five
years ago you could see it in my
documentary
I'll link you I will link you yeah I was
I couldn't believe it it was huge no you
know you know I don't know who's as big
but believe me when I saw mine I said
this this is not normal no my mine was
like so my testicles and my my balls
swole up I'm not even joking to the size
of like a like an overly like a super
GMO
wow that sounds painful
you know it's crazy I was dating this
beautiful Chinese girl at the time and
she took lotion and like rubbed it all
over me took camera I couldn't even
believe a woman would do this yeah
so yeah yeah yeah and she massaged it
and she took care of it
I saw a deeper side of female love
during that time
well I hope she wasn't small framed in
because you really do damage there
didn't even get a ring huh
I don't think she'll ever forget me
though
I'm gonna I'm gonna Read Super chats for
a second
um uh to the girl on the couch there's a
difference between LDL cholesterol and
HDL LDL builds up when eating processed
seeds and hydrogenated oil like canola
HDL is good also we do need cholesterol
to feed our brains and make sex hormones
NSX
red meat only um correlates negatively
when it's part of London modern diet
meat only green veg or a mix of those
show lower risks of heart to be heart
disease and diabetes
um what's removed carbohydrates NSX
obese man I'm self-sterilized due to the
heat downstairs The Twig and berries
need room to stay cool for healthy
fertility facts micro body positivity
but most overweight people I've known
were the meanest people I've known Doug
MPA is it socially acceptable for a fat
person to make fun of a skinny person if
a skinny woman makes fun of a fat woman
then all hell freezes over
um all hell breaks loose sorry The Savvy
doing the The Savvy Ninja outraging on
someone who chooses to get lycos lipos
mini person energy do what you must do
must to evoke the change you desire
um some changes take Extreme Measures
NSX don't mistake good manners with body
positivity mainstream and Health Care
needs to be honest about health concerns
one-to-one Dynamics with people can
still be polite while doing this
honestly a Weaponry Fitness I was 50
pounds overweight last year following a
traumatic situation aside from that my
brother's fat shamed me every day and I
lost the weight in four months wmld it's
one of my clients MPA oh no way yeah the
average woman with a master's degree has
over 103 has a hundred and three
thousand dollars in debt there are too
many economically unattractive women in
the U.S moral for all all of those
juices are full of sugar
um I think I read that one earlier
I just want to make sure there's no
other ones
um okay go ahead when people juice what
do you think they do of course they'll
get a fruit and juicy that's what I
meant it's literally a fruit they
thought you were talking about the you
know the juices that you buy in yeah
raw juice that is the best way raw
juices when you buy those fruit juices
they're like 70 fruit juice like what
the is the other 30 percent this is
not what I signed up for so I have a
question I have a question next question
do you guys think fat shaming can be a
good thing for me yeah no no definitely
not personally me personally
so do you guys do you guys think fat
shaming can be a good thing
sorry sorry sorry
I apologize do you do you think that fat
shaming can be a good thing for me
personally it motivated me to lose
weight I think it was a great thing for
me and I'm very very thankful for it but
other people have different opinions so
um I you didn't interrupt me so you get
to go first go ahead
um so I can remember some years ago
where my mother tapped me on my shoulder
and um and she said uh Pam
um you're just a little bit too big
um at the time I can remember feeling
like oh
I felt really sad but it was truth and I
needed to hear that yeah
um and it was shortly after I'd had I
think my third uh baby
um but I was I kept with the habits so I
had really bad habits and Looking Back
Now
um at the time I was quite offended by
that and I was upset what are those
habits if you don't mind me asking um so
just the eating of lots of chocolate I
had a sweet tooth that was my issue and
also there was yeah that was chocolate
and there was gato cakes and there was I
used to have when I was a kid I used to
have Club biscuits underneath my pillow
and whenever I was in a particular type
of mood because it has it's it's
catch-20 too because you need the sugar
because it's now controlling your mood
it's dictating
did you grow up poorer uh yeah pretty
much me too um so therefore I had there
was there we didn't have a variation of
foods around food was just like it was
like money and it was like yeah I got
food whatever it was
um and so for me it was for me to be
able to have the sweets whatever it was
I was getting a sugar is what I felt I
needed so that became a habit and I took
that habit into adulthood so when my mum
who was the first person to come and say
to me Pam you're a little bit too big
you know because even the the father of
my children he used to bring me
chocolates
that was a way to shut me up oh bring me
the chocolates and I'll eat them and
then everybody's happy in the house
um but again that became a habit so even
now even though I've had a tummy tuck
and I've had lipo
um if I'm feeling a particular way there
are times when I will you know wouldn't
so much get there forever shape but I
might have a healthier chocolate or you
know a dark chocolate perhaps but I need
to have that Sugar fix yeah um and I
think that now
we can we we can still have those those
types of behaviors they can still linger
about even when you you know you might
look good but again are you healthy
sugar is sugar is way more addicting
sugar is more addicting than cocaine you
know that yeah
I know you've never I know you've never
done cocaine Pearl but
I've been at Columbia a couple times let
me tell you something like it's crazy
how addictive sugar is isn't it and it's
honestly in in the United States sugar
is in everything it's in you know it's
in bread yeah in the states it's high
fructose syrup is in the bread there's
sugar in every single thing in the
states and that's the side that's the
main reason why so many people are fat
in States because everything has sugar
in it the salad dressing has sugar in it
people like I'm gonna be healthy I'm
gonna eat a salad and they have
salad dressing that has sugar and all
these seed oils in it so we're living in
this like kind of contaminant world but
there's a lot of people making these
breakthroughs and coming through and
understanding like the fundamentals of
nutritional science and putting it into
food thank God you know but like the
average person is just so poorly
uneducated do you remember the food
pyramid
do you remember it the food pyramid said
you needed to eat six to 11 servings of
bread or rice a day can you imagine 11
pounds of rice a day 11 cups of rice a
day but you know what it's your it's
your it's your responsibility to educate
yourself on nutrition I was dumb I
trusted the government
years ago I did but when I got really
fat when I told you when I went vegan I
started looking at what is in the food
and the ingredients it's up to you to
educate yourself yes it is going to show
you that because unless you educate
yourself but now that we have social
media it's become a lot easier but if
you think about years ago we didn't have
you know now now ketchup is considered a
fruit in the food pyramid of the United
States
is process is the key word here is
process sugar if it was from a sugarcane
if it was from a fruit and and yeah it's
not true sugar so it's actually the
process is the key word not sugarcane
but because honey honey not too raw
honey I don't know I when I was a kid I
was I was also a chunky kid I lost the
weight when I started sports but the
habits continued you know what I mean
yeah yeah and they persist yeah and and
I I know how to make really good um
cookies from scratch and it's with all
natural stuff because you're making it
from scratch and
that made me pretty fast
I used to eat like half of the cookie
dough when I was a kid
diet
like American diet is just so
unfortunately unhealthy like you know do
you know which country has the lowest
obesity rate in the world in Japan
no no no no no no I thought it was like
Mediterranean food had the Iceland no no
no it's Vietnam yeah and if you ever go
to Vietnam if you eat there it's like
first of all if you go to Vietnam it's
just like a giant it's like a small City
in a jungle and Vietnamese people eat so
healthy they eat Natural Foods there's
not a lot of GMOs nonsense you know you
know Vietnam has one of the lowest
divorce rates in the world too seven
percent have you been to Vietnam that's
the place I want to go to this is
not Vietnamese food that's money it's
good and I used to have a boy called
Lena when I was in primary school as
well he was Vietnamese yeah so like you
know the food when you eat there too and
I've noticed this because you know I
travel a lot I'm like I'm addicted to
traveling but honestly every time I go
back to America and I start eating
American food I get like uploaded
stomach yeah digestion issues and and I
yeah no yeah
I'm vegan yeah if I ever eat because
obviously I've grown up on processed
food I've grown up with me you know and
you know fish and all that kind of thing
so when I go back to eating
those kind of foods yeah it does it
affects me yeah I can yeah I went to I
just went to United States and every
time I go back to America I just have to
eat Chick-fil-A just happy Chick-fil-A
but I eat it I eat a breakfast I eat
like the Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich
right the or the breakfast biscuit or
whatever and then my stomach I look like
I'm three months pregnant like it just
blows me up and I'm miserable for the
rest of the day you know what my trick
is for me for that if I do eat something
I I am bloated I have a a waist trainer
that I wear and I don't know I'm not
sure
I can think my waist trainer is in my
bag
let's let's explore what what waist
trainers do for people and two people
yeah right because waist trainers you
know they used to be used for posture
correction and yeah you have like uh you
know post surgery garments like far yes
but if you are just putting on a waist
trainer and let's say you're wearing it
for extended periods of time because
you're super committed to having a
snatched waist what is that doing to
your organs well I've been doing it for
five years
I've been wearing it for five years I
just can't see waist trainers being as
big of a problem as obesity no I'm not
saying yes I'm not saying this to a
company no no and I'm saying I think
that's why we focus on Obesity a lot
more is because it's just a way bigger
problem
um I you guys would always clown I'm so
tired of the UK clowning on America for
being overweight because I looked up the
stats
but U.S is massive U.S is massive but I
will say this it's like it's like okay I
think we're like 70 overweight and you
guys are like 60 yeah
I don't I think they're in the hillbilly
sides of of England because like in
London I don't know I I was expecting to
see a bunch of fatties here gorgeous
good women here because I think I think
it's because everybody's walking all the
time here you know what I mean that's
like when I first yeah Australians are
pretty fat like I I was dry like I drove
everywhere in Australia yeah I move here
four months 10 kilos gone and you're
walking I didn't change my diet nothing
everything was the same 25 of adults in
England are obese
[Laughter]
I got trouble so I'll tell you lady
something I recently got in trouble
right because I I like I trolled chats
once in a while and there was a there
was a girl that was on there was a girl
that was on a show and no disrespect to
her it is what it is but you know she
was I mean objectively speaking she was
a little bit on the chubbier side and I
just wrote who is this chubby woman and
then I wrote hahaha and then I wrote
she's she's about 40 pounds too heavy
for me for my personal preference right
yeah and
she it was really really really really
upset that I said this
and
the reality is though like if you look
at her like her weight is still what it
is yeah but she like vilified me and
demonized she could have ran a marathon
like I did
you know it's like it like so I went to
America and basically a a girl got angry
because
I said she was a little heavier than I
preferred for my sexual preference I
I don't think it matters how he says it
I think his women were too soft and we
need to get bigger scared and especially
if he's making fun of something that you
can change because we've been in front
of short men all the time and until we
stop doing that yeah until we stop doing
that we have no right to tell men what
they can and can't prefer it was like a
peek of me it was a it was a peak
America experience too because basically
I went to America and a fat girl got mad
at me because she was fat well
there was no truth in that you weren't a
bit of angry as she was yeah did you
trigger her anyway
what did you do we need at least hear
this because I don't get angry I wrote
those three things in the chat that's
all I did sometimes sometimes the truth
needs to be told some people need yeah I
agree I guess
like celebrities like these lizzo will
lead their weight
it's because she's in these super
scantily like she's wearing basically
nothing and that is what she's leading
with and then she gets mad when when
people comment on her way Adele was
overweight nobody commented on them
because she didn't lead with it until
she lost it then they commented
and then they said that she might have
not been well when she lost the weight
yeah that's like Fat Amy as well like
she's known as Fat Amy but like she's
lost all that weight and she looks
amazing
that was from walking yeah all she did
was walk and even lizzo She Wore like a
thong to a basketball game kids
I think that's a separate thing she
should have just covered up you look at
her Instagram she knows kids follow her
it looks like softcore porn
it's like if an Instagram model leads
with her body yeah and Men call her yeah
like if if an Instagram even a thin one
it's like an Instagram model she's
wearing nothing and then people call her
a while you're leading with that so
let me ask you a question then so I'm
sitting here I'm wearing I don't know
what this is called but it doesn't have
the boob tube boob tube there we go I
don't know my fashion so if I had a
smaller chest people probably wouldn't
pick up on the fact that I'm wearing a
boob tube right but because I have
breasts and they are quite large someone
might go oh she's got big boobs and she
isn't she dressed a bit funnily like
she's putting her weight out there am I
putting my weight out there or am I just
wearing clothes I mean I would say
you're putting your boobs out there like
if something come out yeah are you
putting your boobs out there I would say
no because I'm not built the same as you
okay so it's subjective So based on what
we can see so if you can't see my boobs
and we can see yours but am I leading
with my weight based on what I've put on
top I wouldn't say you're leading with
your weight I'd say that like your boobs
are very like they're out they yeah they
are literally this is way more
sexualized than you are honestly
absolutely is yeah we're not saying
yeah but one point is valid though if
you see a woman walking down the street
in that top with your size breasts
compared to someone with a 32 double A
you are not going to look at that woman
in the same way
but I think life isn't fair I'm tall
yeah
I'll tell you a story when I was in high
school I got kicked out of homecoming
because I had like a day to find my
volleyball dress and I couldn't find one
that fit me because I just waited too
long and so it was way too short and
they sent me home and I could have
whined and been like oh poor me no like
I waited till the last minute and that
was the that was the hand done
there's an in there's in regards to like
you know like what Sophie said you know
Sophie right yeah yeah so Sophie said
earlier like she just ignores guys that
are like five foot five like I'm the
same way when I see almost a cup I'm
like I don't see anything here you know
and they did it they did they did a
study too like the way women like
disproportionately desire a man that is
super tall because like tall men are
really really short a small percentage
of the population that's the same way
guys want women with big breasts did you
know that I I have like the big breasts
like because they did a lot of um data
based upon men's preferences and then
like the guys who are ordering sex dolls
the guys who are ordering sex dolls the
average breast size they wanted was
American D cup or larger wow you know
I'm a boot man myself too I'm old school
I don't this whole new ass thing I'm not
about it
what about that you
know but you know
call you misogynistic for that
preference
chat GPT has me listed as a misogynist
personal preference
I have a question on on preferences so
if I said hey guys men don't like
old fat single mothers is that offensive
to you
well I I would want to know why what's
what's because men just don't typically
pick women that are older their their
options go down on dating apps but men
don't typically pick women that are
fatter their options
and Men also don't typically pick women
with kids other options go down okay all
right so I'm I'm I I have children will
although they're adults
um I'm an older woman yeah but you're
sexy
[Laughter]
though they
you're clearly an exception to the role
in those rare cases
so who are we speaking about here
non-sexy women
look at how we have sex or sexiness
differently it says
do you think you're equally like do you
think I think I had you at 20 with no
kids versus you now with four kids who
are they picking four grandkids I think
she has three kids three kids four
grandkids right probably now but not
because of the way that I look but
because I'm a very much a healed person
of the person I used to be the way you
are the way I am now and who I am I'm
telling you most man will just just for
sex only for sex only sex only with
another scene will now there we go I I
get that the majority majority because
again it's eye candy isn't it we all
want a bit of my candy yeah you know men
think sex first relationship after I've
got a friend I got a friend I got a
friend that actually lacks older women
that so there's two sides to the men who
like older women it's a little dark so
one side is like they may have been you
know
by a older woman when she was younger or
or
older women is all he can get so he
fetishizes it he's like I like it that's
interesting because I know a few people
um
on social media myself that prefer older
women
your your male friends prefer older
women some of them how old are they are
these guys like good looking chats are
they like good looking chats he's good
looking like I would go there with some
of them yes is his mother present in his
life
I don't know that much
well my friend older women sometimes
want younger men as well
for example I'm 43 yeah so you don't
look it tell the guys my age I'm younger
necessarily look that great
so I would not really potentially like I
would not really have a choice
my choice would not be older men
but if I had the choice I would go for
younger because I personally believe
that younger men just look better than
the guys my age
perform better
it's actually a normal
um like that happens a lot older women
with younger men but it's because men
don't have as much leverage on the
sexual Marketplace so men like their
their Peak if you look at dating apps
where they have the most options it's
like roughly around like 35 to 37. where
women have the most options roughly
around like 22. yeah yeah imagine for me
I I'm the men that I attract now I mean
there's a variation in ages but a
majority of they're not they're not even
as old as my oldest son younger right no
they are I know I know right that's the
point because they don't have as many
options when men are young they can't
they can't sleep with as many women they
have less options so it's like the older
women have less options and the younger
men have less options so they tend to go
together yeah where it's like the the 35
year olds like typically date the
younger the younger women and I'm not
saying like how am I like like I think
the average age Gap is like like each
prefer like five to seven years
difference but but it starts with locks
and men find 22 year olds the most I
will say this too at right now because
with the way Society is structured like
men are just being slammed with sexual
images non-stop like the moment we wake
up like how about some sex you know yeah
and so this has caused male thirst to be
at an all-time high yeah and so dudes
are like a you know when guys get good
with game and you know getting with a
bunch of women that sex that ejaculation
that hunt is all based upon dopamine and
so you got these guys are just
searching for that next dopamine hit you
know what I mean and then also I don't
think we've ever had a period in time
where older women were doing their best
to stay sexy you know I mean I think
like back in the day they'd be like you
know yeah you know you have like the
JLo's and you got all these different
women I don't give up celebrities but
not jayla's the only one I know but like
you know they're they're older women in
their 40s and 50s right that are like
trying to be super sexy so when you're
sexy you know guys are dogs guys are
dogs and so they're gonna come
after you yeah but I also think it
doesn't really count until you're until
you're married really or in a long-term
relationship with kids because that
seems to be the new marriage nowadays
because I think a lot of times as women
we'll mistake sexual attention for
relationship attention and they're not
the same that's huge yeah but because a
lot of women they'll conflate the fact
that a million dudes are in their DMS
right and like hollering at them but I
would say 99 of those dudes they're
gonna you a couple times and
disappear yeah and then you're gonna be
like Oh I thought he liked me
where are the best places to look see
see you know what here's the thing I
know I'm like a red pill guy and I'm
supposed to like on women because
that's like what the majority of people
do but that even for me is something
that I have been trying to answer the
question to I can't tell these women
where to find good men but I gotta tell
them where not to find them
we're not any dating
apps any dating app bars any if he has
any kind of drug addiction no yes right
Church used to be a stable thing but
honestly I would say this the guys that
you ignore are probably going to be
someone with better relationship yeah
the guys that don't even show up on your
radar yeah because it's just it is hard
because for guys
you know when mainstream media and
mainstream culture is just telling Girls
by default to be to be to
sleep around right it's really hard so
that's the conundrum we have right now
is like good women
are usually trying so hard to find good
men and good men are trying so hard to
find good women because for me too after
I became successful it's just like ha I
don't even know like where to like find
decent women because like women who like
you for your clout or for your money or
all those things you know it's just like
this is treacherous like she's
after me yeah but for things that I have
not me David once you have a following
is so different oh dude I have trauma I
want to go to a monastery like is it
because because it's just it's so for
some talk from a guy's perspective it's
so hard to
one vet a woman and find out the truth
of who she is see I like him she knows
exactly yeah and and then on the other
side of the coin it's the same thing for
ladies because you're blinded by your
own attraction like I like this person
well they did this like this means they
like me but then like you know when you
go through a situation when you thought
someone loved you you thought they liked
you a lot and then you find out that
yeah they didn't and then they leave
quickly they don't want to resolve
conflict or whatever then you're just
sitting there like damn I just really
don't know I went through that I I
literally went through that someone who
I thought was on my team
um who I I you know I gave myself to and
we thought I thought we were on the same
page and then you later on find out it
was it was not the it was not being
reciprocated yeah and and that's where
you have to draw every piece what
happened
uh without going into too much detail um
[Laughter]
someone whom uh when I just when I began
communicating with him um of what I had
previously been through which allowed me
to drop my guard
um and I was happy to do so because
um he made me feel safe okay um and I
think for him it may have been what he
could get uh but I think the worst thing
for me was there was no resolution it
was a straight cut off
I mean when it when things kind of sort
of came about and
um you know when things really mattered
and we should have been communicating we
should have been speaking about it
speaking about the very small issue it
was a very very small issue
um what issue was that it was a very
small issue
um it literally there was no
conversation
but we did we didn't get to speak about
what the problem was did you leave or
did he leave he did oh so he left and
then you just never heard and I never
heard was he younger no he was older so
can I say that emotional labor it does
not come with a marker I don't think
that you can you know be on a dating app
or be in church or whatever see someone
meet them be on a date with them and say
yes this person is willing and committed
to put in emotional labor to make this
work that you only know that yeah when
you come up to those those situations
I actually don't really think men should
care about our emotional needs no I
don't think she means emotionally like
you know when you get to a point in a
relationship where there's like a a
Breaking Point yeah where the both of
you are going to have to endure through
a I wasn't even I'm not even trying to
be yeah yeah but like when you have to
like endure through hardship absolutely
you know some people they just give up
yeah yeah and it's and it's detrimental
because I've I've been that I've been
that person who didn't want to give up I
was like you know and I wanted to be
committed to the situation where when
your partner gives up and then that's
just like and unfortunately I just don't
understand how that like works because
you're not because you're not a dirt bag
that's why because
emotional labor like I I always hear
that I don't really hear that term used
then I usually hear it when it's like my
partner's not meeting my emotional needs
that's what I hear when I hear emotional
no I think she's talking about because
there's no points what do you mean I
would say that the emotional labor is
any situation that you come up against
as a partnership where there requires
some either compromise or you two have
to sit down and have a difficult
discussion about you know did the kids
go to school here or there or you know
you know it's just anything I think I
think the man should automatically
decide
I do I do I believe in I Believe In
traditional relationships which are a
bit different than like 50 50. so which
which basically like a lot of times
women we want the guy to pay for
everything we want we want to like a
traditional outcome where he he pays for
us he leads he's masculine but we're
supposed to give up with that is
Authority yeah and can I add on to
because I you tell me if I'm wrong
because this was your original statement
but I'm just going to add on to it I
think what she means by emotional labor
is like again like it will get to a
point where you will have a hard time
like you both need to push through an
obstacle and I think that the example
she gave well you know the schooling
whatever was more about like there's
going to be emotional turmoil and
conflict but I have an example just so I
could understand better what you're
talking about let's just say you know
you're both at an impasse where you're
just like there there's a communication
barrier like you're saying one thing and
I'm saying another thing right and we
really don't see eye to eye and we
should just keep on trying to push
through keep on trying to communicate
and get through it that's what a
relationship that works looks like but
one party man or woman the emotional
labor social issue
yeah I have okay everyone says I haven't
but I have okay
virgin Vibes
let's take you at your word then so
you've been in a relationship have you
ever had to make a decision in that
relationship either you say that you
believe in traditional relationships no
I think I think one I think traditional
relationships work better because if you
look at the history of them
relationships tend to work better in
countries that have more traditional
relationships and you know if you look
at a hundred years ago 95 percent of
people were married but I'll say no I
wasn't a good girlfriend I think that's
why we broke up I'm not sure because
this is the question which which part
have you ever had a confrontation or a
disagreement with your partner ever in
history yeah and the result of that
confrontation was what have you ever
broken up over a disagreement
irreconcilable differences
um yeah yeah it was more different
values though so it was like it was kind
of getting to the point where we've been
dating a bit and it was either we're
going to get you know married take that
next step or we're not and I just didn't
see us getting married because our
backgrounds were just a bit too
different and do you think that um sort
of unwillingness to compromise was
um would you say that that's a lack of
emotional labor to see where the other
person is coming from and make the
necessary adjustments um I would say
there's different situations
um where I definitely did not compromise
and I should have like um but in that
situation I think it's just picking what
you want to marry okay you know like I
think before you get married you should
weigh out what you want do you think
everything can be known before you get
into that situation or are there are
there instances in the relationship
where you go you discover things about
them and you have to decide at that
point you're you're at a sort of
decision point you have to say I want to
marry this person we're going to work it
out or actually this is a bit too
difficult and I'm not willing to
compromise on this and neither are they
so we have to part ways yeah um do do I
think there's situations where issues
come up and you might find out something
about him or he might find out something
he's like oh you slept with a hundred
people what like they can't compromise
on that or whatever it is you know but
that's not that's not that's not like a
compromise it's more of like a deception
thing yeah which is ties into trust
which if you don't have trust in
relationship it's game over yeah yeah
um but does that answer your question
well I I wonder if are we on the same
page here do we do we
do that I see the I I get it you're
trying to find the answers of why she
believes that and you're yeah
you want to understand why and once it
feels like that I guess I understand the
emotional labor point because I've been
through that and then you know and it's
so because when you're in the
relationship too you know you feel like
a fool because you're like damn like I'm
willing to push through here
[Laughter]
hello
it's the fact that they give up yes at a
point when if you when you had that
discussion about you know how you'd like
things to be conducted or how you would
deal with the matter if the matter ever
arose and the fact that they give up
yeah to me that's disheartening so
that's the hardest thing I will give
everybody what they want which is the
attempt the the ability to throw shade
at their exes so
but the reality of the situation is this
it's not that they just gave up on you
they're just quitters in general yeah
yeah yeah they know how many times and
you're you can reflect on your cases
yeah how many times did they give up on
you and went off and that happily ever
after or are they still jumping from
person to person to person
I've broken up with all mine so
just put it out so you're the you're the
person you're the quitter
she's the queen I know I'm selfish girl
knows what you've got to get that's what
it is and the reason why I did it
personally was because I felt and I've
had a conversation with him at the point
as I felt that I was being
you know let down in a way because I
wasn't able to do what I wanted to do
and I felt like it was always about him
yeah and he would always put himself
first he goes oh I've done this I've
done this and I go well yeah I get you
done that and I support you in that and
I want you to like keep going with it
but then at the end of the day he wasn't
making me feel the way that I felt that
I was giving it to him it wasn't
receptive yeah yeah exactly because
relationships have to be a pendulum
right it works both ways yes both ways
absolutely and if one person's doing
more than the other it's just it's not
gonna work I think when we get into the
habit of keeping score I think that in
itself is destructive that's amazing
yeah I don't know like what a lot of
times I don't know what we think
marriage is supposed to be given like
marriage is actually no it's not
supposed to be if you look at like truly
traditional marriage it's not supposed
to be about us yeah when they say like
you know a relationship should be 50 50.
that's it should be a hundred a
hundred like I give 100 of my effort you
give 100 yeah because when you start
getting to the point because I could
easily be like well
laughs
when was the last time you paid for
dinner you know what was the last time
when was the last time you ubered me
home yes
what is that you know I could I could
break down the I have an
accountant I can easily do that but then
you start getting into like that dark
side of relationships where you're like
keeping score and it's just dirty at
that point you're like okay
and I'm not and I'm not saying this to
like pick on you but I think honestly
like it kind of reveals more if you say
I'm doing more for him than he's doing
for me like I think it reveals more
about you than him because it's showing
that you're the type of person to keep
score of what the other like we're not
supposed to like we're supposed to give
selflessly yeah and like that's what
like if you look at a traditional wife a
traditional mother they're not keeping
score oh I did this much for that kid I
did this much for my husband they're
selfless yeah no your mom's never like
well listen I scratched your back for
like three days so now I gotta ignore
you for the next three days a little
you know that doesn't work like
that but again I think because it just
goes back to what our what's happening
now with our modern times I think
Humanity as of right now is probably at
an all-time I'm high for narcissism
and yeah we've lost Traditional Values
we're just everybody's so full of
themselves everybody thinks they're
better looking than they are everybody
thinks they are cooler than they are
yeah everybody thinks they're sexier
than they are everybody thinks they're
smarter than they are everybody thinks
that their political views the fact that
we even mention political views at all
in itself shows us how much we've been
psyopped by the big four tech
companies you know what I mean so we
have all these things that are you know
symptoms of our modern culture but the
thing is this and I've said it on
multiple podcasts this week here on the
Josh Broly things podcast and I'll
continue to say it when you are
continuously focused on yourself and
you're like me me me me that's who you
end up with because focusing on me me me
is selfish you got to focus on the we
because we are all in this together
anything you want in this life you're
going to hear from another human period
right even if it's from a AI
because that's a question now a human
man that AI God damn it
there's no such thing as self-made as
well no yeah exactly Arnold
Schwarzenegger
in his recent documentary Arnold
Schwarzenegger said in his recent
documentary we talked about you know
there's no such thing as self-made
because that's anybody here
Pamela you know all you ladies here who
lost weight whatever
um you lost weight because somebody
probably from the outside inspired you
somebody helped you yeah you know what I
mean so this whole me me it's
disgusting and I I you know I tell us I
told this to somebody in my life and I
told her I said if you keep on trying to
be this boss babe and me me me me that's
who you're gonna end up with yeah just
yourself yeah well and that's like the
other thing why I say like body
positivity
being obese has negative effects for all
the people that care about you because
one you may die young and two if you
have health issues they're the ones that
are going to have to take care of you
yeah I feel like it's come to a point
big people know the the risk that
they're putting them through and yeah
and just like when I make that when I
make that choice how is that how is that
fair to everyone else like it's either
the taxpayers have to pay the family has
to pay and take care of like it's like
how is that fair to everyone else
do you have that video as sad as it is
um people go through different things in
life obesity just doesn't link with just
because they want to eat it's mental
health it's Finance it's all these
families cultures what maybe they eat a
certain type of time
but these are just excuses because at
the end of the day
no I'm not saying they can't contribute
but at the end of the day your life is
your choices yeah but you don't think
about your life as a choice when you're
in it because you can't look past
tomorrow you're trying to just get past
that day look past tomorrow so you can't
you're not looking at it and we can we
can have sympathy but it's still an
excuse if you're using it as a reason
not to lose
what are you saying Pam like if to be to
be a fat person to be someone who's over
with and to be unhealthy sometimes
you're trapped you've got nowhere else
to go you lack motivation you lack
finances you don't have friendships
you're not in the community so therefore
you're trapped now I'm not saying that
it's it's a reasonable excuse you can
get out there because you've got two
legs you can get out there but you can't
because mentally you are you are down
you are drained and you have no place to
go because you don't know you're not
educated enough yeah I think that's what
it is
it goes back to the the undereducated
because there was a guy actually I
believe he was Irish and he was like 360
pounds have you heard about this guy and
he just he didn't eat for a year he
fasted for a year and he lost that place
because because that's because that's
what fat is fat is he's a team I've been
vaccine many times I just don't think
there's an excuse because of the
internet like I I know someone that's in
a wheelchair that's jacked in a
wheelchair
there's no excuse I've been to a gym
I've been to a gym being all happy being
all confident I'm gonna work out today
and people do laugh for no reason then
does that mean that you're consistent
within it I'm not going to gym now at
the moment I'm just walking exercise and
dancing even if you're educated with
food and nutrition like I was before I
gained weight it's not I knew that what
I was doing wasn't doing myself or my
body any good I was educated I've always
been really healthy with food but at
that particular point and moment in my
life I wasn't and all that went out the
window it yeah it does it went with me
but again it's not an excuse me that's
my point blame it on these things
contributing factors that can take over
your whole life
point is I I can I know so many people
that have had each of the excuses that
you guys are listing I know people with
no legs that lost the way yeah and and
again that's why I say anyone who says
they can't like two people you can't
it's mindset
because I agree with pearl and because
of the sense of this look it's it's an
uncomfortable reality but the reality is
this even if you wanted to lose weight
you can Implement a fasting regimen
which is free yeah
stop eating okay and walk for an
hour a day can I show you a 24 hour hold
on they're 24 hours in a day you walk
for an hour a day because if you are
looking in the mirror and you're unhappy
because you're obese you're fat or
whatever
limit your eating window
choose what calories you take into
yourself and then walk for an hour a day
10 000 steps a day okay your your iPhone
has a step tracker in it do you guys
know there's a step tracker in your
iPhone I'm wearing my auto ring right
now where I track all my calories my
sleeping everything through this
and the thing no no it's not I mean I
agree with you what you're saying about
the mentality but
at the same time it is possible for all
people of all Races of all genders of
all economic statuses too fast and walk
yeah for an hour a day I don't I mean
Pam do you disagree with me like when I
say is that wrong I agree with you yeah
and and I think it's and you know it's
sad because the government is constantly
saying you know just eat seven pounds of
bread a day
so basically my thing is I was always
big bigger and
um just only two and a half years ago I
didn't realize how depressed I was but
once I accepted my troll man what I went
through you know I said I lost I was 28
Stones yeah
I've got a certain sense and certain
understandings of some one day I just
woke up and I felt like oh damn this is
how it is and I looked in the mirror and
I honestly was like oh gosh this is me
and it's almost like when I understood
my trauma I started losing weights
so that's why I said you know when
people have trauma and they're yeah and
they're obese they're actually dealing
when you recognize it you know it catch
it then you can find a way forward until
you accept that and that's happened to
you you will not no but everyone and I
think I think that's why it's hard for
you to see it Pearl because you grew up
with like a nice family you didn't have
to deal with a lot of trauma your dad
wasn't whooping your ass when your wings
when you were growing up you know what I
mean when you because that's what I do
in the inner game healing Summit you
know the inner game healing endure thing
is I work I have a team of guys that
we're all experts and we talk to men and
we talk about healing the traumas right
we do a lot of hypnotherapy and we do an
identification exercise where we
identify the trauma and we figure out
what exactly is happening why am I
traumatized what happened to me and then
going back to it identifying the trauma
and then
coming to peace with getting some
catharsis from the situation healing
them giving them closure on the trauma
because that's what trauma is trauma is
a because trauma is a loop yeah you know
what I mean that's why that's why people
cut themselves that's why people overeat
because when they cut themselves it is a
it is a temporary release and a lot of
people use sex as well as a coping
mechanism coping mechanism for trauma
people use food they use drugs these
prostitutes gambling video games drugs I
mean you name it so when you with the
thing is though because it's just
um I agree because I hope you have to
stop listen let me let me just finish
let me finish let me finish because the
point I'm trying to make is that it is a
it is definitely a first world problem
it is a very first world problem it is a
very first world problem it is the very
first world problem but that's what
happens when you have these traumas and
you do not heal them then what ends up
happening is you just keep on getting on
this okay self-sabotage instruction go
ahead I think people in the western
world use trauma as an excuse there is
no such thing as trauma in the western
world if you go to their countries that
experience real trauma and the people
are not overweight bro I I just don't
believe in that I think it's a crutch to
remove accountability from people and to
give people an excuse to not do what
needs to be done but I have these people
got access to food are easy easily
accessible that's the question Africa is
not it's not a jungle
Foods
I'm from Bangladesh my parents are where
people the way people approach their
problems is different yeah can I ask you
this I think you came from a fully
intact family mother father yeah that's
good see I think that's the problem
because a lot of a lot of the western
is like the families are like we
have all the money in the world but the
families are so broken yeah and then you
know because they were there were there
were two girls on a podcast I was at
recently right and one girl was like my
father was present from zero to thirteen
very normal very beautiful girl and
another girl was like my father was
present more like my stepfather was
president from 13 onwards and she was
just permanently angry so when in these
developmental stage of the developmental
parts of our Lives because in America
women are incentivized to throw the
father out from the children being one
two three and then you're growing up
with this empty position
fathers used to go to warning like they
used to be spot but that's what I'm
saying like I just it's just something
but but they were they did go to war but
the Mother wasn't at home be like your
father's a loser
out there like fighting for the country
like the most masculine esteem thing you
can do no I'm not saying trauma doesn't
exist I just think like 80 of the time
when I hear trauma it's just an excuse I
will say this I'm gonna push back
because you and Myron have the same
position on this right but you and Myron
were also raised and very healthy like
functioning families I was like severely
emotionally abused mentally abused and
physically abused for like the majority
of my childhood and when you are
undergoing these kind of things during
your formative years you have a
traumatic outlook on life period it
changes your perception and I know it
sounds like I'm coping but I'm not I'm
telling you and it's a hard thing for
people who are not traumatized to look
at this from an outside lens because
there's a there's things you have to
overcome I have a question
how much more traumatic can you get for
a child to grow up in a situation where
it's encouraged for you to be beat by
your parents as discipline
because that's how African kids are
raised
so let me like let me ask you this how
how traumatic would it be for you to
grow up never knowing who your father
was
I mean
as a kid every day I got beaten okay if
you saw what if you saw your parent your
one of your parents get beaten by your
other parent as a child yeah
so how could you not say that that
trauma would affect somebody and you'd
use it as an excuse because I've not
seen that I know I know different types
of trauma affect different kinds of
people but I think the problem is we
blame the trauma and we we remove that
accountability yeah you choose how to
react from that because they're children
that come from the same home where the
father was abusive and one goes on to be
successful in life and one has a
completely useless life can I jump in
I'm sorry
a lot of people that I met who have gone
seen stuff from childhood I'm sure they
either carry on or they they they they
they express it in another way they
don't answer healthy way this is all
it's irrelevant this is absolutely
irrelevant it doesn't matter how you
become traumatized it's about how you
hit your rock bottom that forces you to
go backwards but trauma is irrelevant
it's the rock bottom that matters we're
saying that sugar is a drug right what
happens to drug addicts so you have a
sponsor and your sponsor might say you
know you do like a day or two clean and
it's you know Well Done congratulations
and then they get back onto the drugs
they relapse and their sponsor or the
you know the expert says their support
worker says you haven't hit your Rock
Bottom because they haven't it doesn't
matter what your trauma is it matters
what stops you from like yeah yeah I
definitely I'd say I'm going to say
disagree with you on that in the sense
because I exclusively run a community of
traumatized individuals and our main
goal is to overcome the trauma because
here's the thing if you don't overcome
your trauma you're gonna get caught in a
pattern of self-sabotage are you earlier
were mentioning that you know people who
may have gained a lot of weight they'll
lose 100 pounds but they're still
traumatized in their head and their
subconscious mind is still traumatized
so they will rebound upwards because
they're gonna match to what's going on
here because you have to
come to closure with your trauma that's
what that's what hold on hold on wait
wait wait that's what that's the goal of
all psychological training is it's
catharsis do you know catharsis is yeah
catharsis you should look this up
catharsis is emotional release and which
is coming to closure from your troubled
past your trauma and all those things
and that's why that's why you you see
somebody who like how many people don't
you think it goes back to still the
person though and what you choose to do
with it instead of the trauma because
it's like again but then that's what
pain let me finish okay it's like that
girl came back from like North Korea
yeah at least you've seen that where she
she came out of North Korea she
literally was sold as a sex slave to get
out in China yeah and she came back and
she's like
they were telling her to go to therapy
and she's like I don't even understand
this she's like
and then she's talking about how her her
um her roommates like we're going to
therapy over their cheating boyfriends
she's like I just don't understand that
so the reason roommates like so so like
isn't it based on
like I just think it's based on like the
person you know because I'll know people
that like they're like he was saying
they're siblings and one will turn out
great and one will go crazy yeah and
then it goes back but it does go back to
the trauma I'm telling you it's a big
thing right now and that's the reason
that's why people are so up and
what Pam was saying is true like your
environments can keep you trapped in
your trauma too yeah as well because
like you know historically speaking too
because not every because another thing
is this
not every therapist is a good therapist
first of all they just did what needed
to be done to get their therapy license
someone as someone who is in school for
if I failed a class this podcast got too
big but
I did I did not pass you know prepare to
be fair to be fair but but I I literally
most of the girls in the psych
Department are nuts oh my God I was like
I was looking around I was just getting
a psych degree for fun I wanted
something easy ironic
but I was like I was looking around I'm
like these are the future therapists
but it's it's not that the is in
the sorry ladies it's not that the women
are the women in the psych departments
are crazy they're all crazy have
you seen the elementary school teacher
Department these girls railing Coke on
the weekends having a wild time but they
handle business when it comes to the
children and I want to say that your
point to my point was not a valid
rebutter all because I said when you hit
rock bottom that's when things start to
change I'm not saying that you don't
need closure from your from your trauma
absolutely but you can only seek that
truck that closure once you hit that hit
rock bottom so I'm not saying that you
don't agree I agree I feel like our
points go hand in hand
you know that for me to know wasn't in a
rebuttal I'm sorry it wasn't a rebuttal
but it was just adding on to the fact
that like because I have seen people
who've hit rock bottom and still didn't
do what was necessary to change which
which was to heal that trauma to come
clear to come to closure with that right
but because I have dealt with people too
who have like I said they had hit rock
bottom but they just
I personally have never hit rock bottom
with my mental health yeah but I was
miserable enough to be like yo this is
something has to change yeah you
know what I mean so that's my big thing
because I think if we're telling
everybody get out there and hit rock
bottom like
it's just not a good thing it's not a
good thing but like what what Pearl and
King said too you know there is an
absolute truth to that in the sense that
we can't sit here and sit around and
feel sorry for ourselves in today's
modern times like I tell this guys I
said to all men and I don't care what
you have to say but if you're a man
and you're after the age of 35 and
you're still financially struggling it
is ten thousand percent your fault
because there's every opportunity in the
world I personally have come from every
low marker abject poverty physically
abuse mentally abuse emotionally abused
everything and I have made Millions with
my business and so for me if I could do
that if I could do that you know I just
I'm an exception to the rule but I am
saying that it is possible do you think
focusing on trauma makes it worse
because I just look at look at I just
look at the results okay I'm not saying
there's no exceptions to this and when I
when I hear girls talk about trauma for
years
I it just they don't seem to get better
when they're always talking about it
and they'll do like therapy for years
I'm like this is supposed to be like 60
understood yes they haven't understood
okay so okay and that goes back goes
back so I just want to walk through this
so if I'm if I'm in a single I'm grow up
I'm in a single mother home okay and and
the trauma was that
um I don't know she hit me and she was
abusive until I was like say I don't
know 15 then I moved out okay now like
what what do you like so we we talk
about it with I just want to know step
by step I want to just add something
before you say something the majority of
therapists
their goal is not to get you better is
to keep you coming back to the next
session yeah first of all yeah because
the majority therapist they this is why
I didn't pursue my doctorate in
Psychology
the average
prescription that they give United
States of America is 12 weeks of therapy
plus drugs and I don't agree with that
does that mean that therapists here do
not have that goal because it's it's
like free isn't it we don't pay for our
prescriptions or the therapy directly or
up front yeah I mean if the government's
in direct control of it I don't trust it
personally okay so it's not Money
Motivated in that sense if you well I
think it is money it is Money Motivated
because it's subsidized by the
government okay
they said that I should be admit I was
like no I don't want I don't I don't
want to take it so it is a thing he's a
money-making scheme therapy
you're only offered six sessions
okay when you're going through something
it's best to not focus on it like for
example when I came out of my trauma I
was like okay now I know I can see
patterns this is what I do this is how I
am I'm not gonna do them that's it
that's it and I'm not gonna also tell
myself
keep on moaning about it because if you
have that mentality it's impossible but
if you're gonna say do you know what
I've been through that I'm gonna forget
it hold me knew me I'm gonna give myself
new habits I'm gonna go for it it does
work it does change things change step
by step so okay I was beat till I was
15. now now what what do you so we we go
to the therapist and I say I was beat
till I was 15.
are you affected by in any way does it
affect you of course that's what we're
talking about this example yeah so what
was that what would you what they would
end up telling you to do is you need to
kind of and it's it's uncomfortable but
you have to like relive those situations
yeah exactly you got to relive those
situations and then you need to identify
your negative associations with that
situation that happened and then they
teach you how to come to peace with it
because a lot of people listen that you
know I knew that woman that yesterday
who mentioned that she was essay
trafficked right and this happens a lot
with women who are graped essay
trafficked whatever they don't really
come to peace with what has happened to
them so that's why she was here and she
like had to continuously mention it to
us and we're like a group of strangers
like anybody with kind of regular
you know functionalities about
themselves would kind of keep that
private you know what I mean if we were
and trafficked across a place or we were
graped for six months in a row but she
had not come to peace with that and
that's also why when I asked her and we
had a little bit of conflict you know
when people you know here's a here's a
good way to understand if someone's
Trump's eyes if you keep on trying to
tell them something they're like keep on
arguing with you you're telling like
calm down let me make my point that's an
indicator of a traumatized person yeah
really I think that's just I just think
that's an indicator of an no no
it is their trauma listen their trauma
is build up and they can't even help
themselves I couldn't have to like come
out and say these things
okay we go back and I say okay this is
what happened she beat me and then I
like then what so now they say accept it
I say okay I've accepted so they can
accept it because when you're beaten
it's like it's literally broken into
your mind in your mind it's there's
almost a point where you have to you to
blame somebody or something yeah so you
have to understand that it's not your
fault yeah that you you did not bring
this on yourself that was the other
person's actions that you didn't have
control over so when you understand that
part of the trauma I know that it was it
was nothing that you could have done to
prevent that and it was not your
behavior you are not responsible for
other people's behavior yeah see I don't
know this stuff might work like in my
mind but but it just to me like outside
looking in it seems nuts because you're
not traumatized no no it's not because
it's because I do these shows and all
these girls will tell me about their
therapy and then they'll still like
everyone like because you guys I know
but I'm saying like you guys were saying
you guys are healed but you both brought
up your trauma on the shows and not you
talking about it which you say you
wouldn't do because it was context to
the situation yeah which is you know
fine I'm not but it just doesn't seem to
like match with what I see like people
getting better from this stuff it might
I don't know I've never gone through it
like it just it just seems like the
majority of people go to therapy and
they get worse no so I would agree with
you and like like I said earlier
traditional therapy is not the answer
right people like I have a friend okay
and he went to 15 years of CBT cognitive
behavioral therapy right and he said it
resolved about five percent of his
traumas
but once he started doing hypnotherapy
and getting down to the core issues
because when you're traumatized okay
when you're traumatized your
subconscious mind which controls
everything about you that is what is
permanently damaged yeah and once that's
damaged it produces a damaged person
that's why you'll take somebody who is
addicted to drugs right you'll put them
in the countryside of Wichita Kansas
they'll be a farmer or whatever but
somehow they'll sneak out in the middle
of night and they'll find crack
because that their subconscious mind
they are traumatizing who they are
that's their identity yeah you know and
it's a and like I said you were raised
in extremely well like healthy household
same thing with Myron too like you guys
are both like you both like say like
trauma's not real and stuff you know
even Tate too right you guys all three
are like very similar in that sense but
hard for non-traumatized people to
understand the reality of people who
were like I was viciously beaten as a
kid like I know this is not me trauma
dumping like oh I feel sorry for me but
like you know when I was like eight
years old I got held up against the wall
and I was hit repeatedly previously I
saw my blood Splat up against this white
wall right as an eight-year-old child
nine-year-old child this happened for a
couple years right that with
your reality it with your
permanent perception of reality and
people just we're still at this point
right now where you're just hard to
understand these things and it's hard to
overcome them I was lucky enough to come
upon a group of people through my
community as I started my YouTube
channel and if you watch my YouTube from
now like now watch me in 2019 2020 I was
like way more toxic way more like
unrefined than I am now and so it's a
very complex puzzle to solve but if you
do do research into understanding the
majority of Psych ecological problems
that are haunting people right now it is
trauma and then the goal of All Therapy
is catharsis which is emotional release
which brings closure to those traumas
[Laughter]
I just think the solution to solving all
these trauma things is not actually
relieving it or talking about it I think
it's actually going out there and doing
incremental steps towards being
proactive different things yeah in terms
of self-improvement yes I agree with the
solution yeah
but you can't poo poo people's trauma
because what everybody's got their own
trauma and it affects them in their own
individual ways
it's the solution yeah I agree the
solution is still the same yeah it is
yeah yeah people's trauma is not well
I'm also tired of people that aren't
really traumatized saying that they're
traumatized like okay that's real like
okay well you were talking about that
that's a real thing but it's like these
girls will come on oh my cheat you got
cheated on okay
here's another thing too when it comes
to trauma right because that's a
new trend like The Tick Tock trauma dump
right there's a lot of girls because
listen when you are a traumatized person
you want to be heard you want people to
tell you everything's okay right and so
these girls vent on Tick Tock and what
do they do what happens they get the
dopamine that they need that they get
the the what is it the validation they
get the dopamine validation and then
like it I'm gonna be like up
to a trauma dump girl right but that's
why that's why you see these girls like
when you see the majorities girls like
fresh and fit all this and like
they they're just so rude and they can't
like stop like you know cutting off the
host because why he says something that
triggers her and then she can't stop
that emotional dump and emotional
release because she's a traumatized
individual so that's my biggest thing I
am not saying for excuses how do you
know she's not just an that
could be it too
that could be it too yeah yeah
I'm gonna give
I'm gonna give a trauma card like real
trauma card where it only counts I mean
we can add to this list if you think I'm
being okay but I I only get that final
six this is myself
I'll give you I'll give you abuse you
know that's that's real yeah
um essay for sure essay yeah
and witnessing a very horrific crime
I'll give you those those three okay
does verbal abuse count
in that domestic abuse yeah because we
were talking about as well
I think the way that verbal abuse is
used nowaday no because the way women
use verbal abuse is very soft
she's like I agree but it's hard
[Laughter]
for you the way the way most people use
abuse today but real abuse but that but
that goes back to the like that's what I
said in the beginning I said assault or
something like being hit being being
abused actually but
and you know
verbally abusing
a child like as a kid I think that's but
if it's in a relationship you're allowed
to break up so yeah no no that the
verbal abuse from a child is strong
because you know when you have these
these positions of authority you're like
for example I'll use my example of my
aunt right she used to tell me like you
are going to burn in the lake fire
forever because you're a bad little kid
and I was like 9 10. I was like
that's like what are you talking about
like I did what did I do you're um but
your mom seems great though so I'm sure
she said it's she's great now but we had
to overcome a lot all right okay okay
yeah she beat the out of me she's
from Trinidad so she beat me like
like no other you know
um Can Trump would be like getting hit
as a kid yeah because because it spikes
your it spikes your uh stress reaction
points in your brain when you're being
viciously beaten so but it's it's
another thing too if you're being beaten
it's one thing but if you're being
beaten and then on top of that there's
emotional View yeah your little
you're a piece of garbage whatever
like I I do I do think someone in the
chat this is a hundred dollar Super Chat
Thane is back you know we missed thing
we're just gonna do hey uh Western he
says westerners crutch his trauma
Westin
[Music]
it's just like okay
you know like beating a kid to the point
of blood okay okay but like sometimes
it's like my mom beat me with the spoon
yeah
I got that too
I literally my dad when I was about 10
years old would
I would run underneath the the dining
table in living room
and then I would okay haha you can't get
me and I would literally run to his
bedroom try and lock the door he got in
and I got soap all in my mouth okay but
imagine imagine if like a therapist
comes in and says let's relive this
trauma
that's what they do is they started they
start to like convince you that you're
trying yeah I I did I did a couple
therapy sessions and I just got some
ears I want to push back for you and so
you were disciplined by your mother
right but you were also and King you too
right you were disciplined by your
parents but you were also loved by them
right A lot of these situations it's
just every day come home and take it out
on the kids take it out on the wife yeah
I think that's a minority of the
situations I think most parents would
discipline and love their kids yeah yeah
but I'm talking about my situation and
and the traumatized situations which are
the rarer situations because yeah
because your parents typically the
average parent is not just gonna beat
your ass because if they have a
conscience they're going to feel bad
they're like oh I beat your ass but like
here's some ice cream I just noticed
whenever there's like criticism of a
person or like you kind of have to look
in the mirror a lot of people just use
like they blame it on the trauma instead
of the person and I think that's what
King's getting at yeah because a lot of
times it just becomes like that yeah I
agree with that but in the you're
talking about the majority which is
right but in the minority it's not
always the case but in all cases isn't
it that the abuse or the trauma may not
be your fault but your healing is your
responsibility once you get to an age of
like you know sentience and you're you
just make whether it affects you or not
absolutely well not just if it affects
you but you know even if it does or even
if it happens
did you guys know that I don't remember
during what period but 10 of our
ancestors were murdered what 10 yeah
yeah if his ancestors everybody's it was
like during an early Pro like I'm I'm
butchering it but I I talked to a um a
guy who wrote the book The History of
sex about it and he talks about how like
in our early ancestors 10 were murdered
so it's like I'm like if people made it
back then you know what are we
complaining about now oh yeah yeah can
you imagine ten percent
dying yeah we are yeah
um okay wait
I want to do the
I think I'm gonna do the the Paulina
part going back to the body pot no it's
not a video but you can show the did you
get the article king I said yeah yeah I
just want the picture so this is um
I actually don't even notice her last
name Paulina
um poor is so poor is is kova who used
to be like um a model back in the day
okay
the supermodel feels sexier than ever
and wants other women to embrace the
Aging pop process Paulina is tired of
dealing with men who think she should
simply fade in the background just
because she's in her 50s this supermodel
has been outspoken with her criticism of
the industry in recent years and has
suggested that women over a certain age
are treated like they're invisible and
it's a topic she elaborates on in great
detail in the interview within the New
York Times I am now completely invisible
she told the publication I walk into a
party I flirt with guys and they will
just walk away from me mid-sentence to
pursue someone 20 years younger
I'm very single I'm dressed up I've made
an effort nothing the 56 year old
describes how she began to feel
invisible when she meets middle aged and
called it a slow fade like the boiled
frog you don't know what you got until
you're until you're gone it's around the
same time my marriage fell apart my
husband was no longer interested in me
and I started looking around and I
realized I was invisible to the
population at large it made me feel
terrible about myself this week she also
shared the message for those who had
taken to social media to say she should
be invisible at her age I'd like to
thank all the men who are now feet on my
feed trolling me
um I that I should be invisible at my
age you're proving my point in a form of
rebellion she has been posting sexy
photos of herself in bikinis nudes and
without makeup and some of the comments
from men aren't kind I started posting
this kind of pictures I that that have
been taking of taken of me since I was
15 she told the times I look good I
didn't realize it would be shocking for
a 50-something-year-old woman to pose in
bikinis from 30 years ago that still fit
it's okay to
to oogle someone who could be your dog
Google someone who could be your
daughter but not mature women who know
themselves and are most likely way
better than at sex in her interview she
said she feels sexier than when she did
when she was younger and she often
intimidates men I am not fluttery
vulnerable creature I'm an active
participant and investigator I know what
I like and how I work I like to have fun
and I know what I'm doing she said that
makes them run away there's another
picture if you scroll down King
she said on the record of she she who is
on the record is never having filed job
or botoxed her face
um according to the times she can see
why many women turn to plastic surgery
that when a woman gets uh gets of these
certain cosmetic procedures she's
actually servicing exactly what you're
trying to oppose we stand up we need to
stand up and insist on not being
invisible she says I wish there were
more women who left their marionette
lines which are the lines that run from
the corner of your mouths forehead lines
and crow's feet I wish there was more
women who dared to age
and recently the ladies of Sex in the
City reboot and just like that have
highlighted the topic of women Aging in
public
it was far from a regular life I would
feel fine I would feel great I'm healthy
I'm strong I've got this three-year-old
son and I carry him around and I'm all
good but no I'm on television where
every bit of my physical being is being
analyzed
the part was always stressful and
difficult for me because as much as I
can look back and think oh I looked
great great then you can never think
that at the time I guess no one does
and then
co-host Sarah Jessica Parker sets her on
there too who plays the framed Carrie
Bradshaw responded to the misogynistic
chatter about her and her fellow
classmates in an interview with Vogue
last year there's so much chatter in
response to us that would never happen
about men it may almost makes people
feel it almost feels as if people don't
want us to be perfectly okay with who we
are and as if they
as if they almost enjoy us being painted
by who we are today whether we choose to
age naturally and not look perfect or
whether you choose to do something that
makes you feel better she added she said
in her interview with the times that the
public still has a ways to go when it
comes to its perception of beauty
so first question
should older women dress and move like
younger women I think everyone has the
right to do what they want no we're not
talking about the right we're saying
should
I think she's just coping she's that was
the longest cope I've ever read my mind
to feel that way but not everyone wants
to see that because if you you may feel
sexy yeah but not everyone wants yeah
people wanted to see that they want to
deny reality like guys get old too women
get old grow the up you're going to
be old you're going to be ugly one day
you're going to be old and horny no
one's going to you yeah
well unless
it's crazy all the stuff she's
complaining about she was a model she
benefited from being yeah
the problem is these women are supposed
to be married nobody cared about women
Aging in public if they weren't acting
like teenagers
by now correct Madonna's out here naked
on the internet Chelsea Handler's
putting her boobs out there but it's
like it's in bed embarrassing to have
women in their 50s and 60s moving like
this yeah because it's just yeah get a
husband and get out of there and that's
that's the problem because the majority
of these girls what they're doing is
they've been sleeping around you're not
locking someone down and then you know
father time comes knocking and he takes
your Youth and you're like I'm old
nobody likes me and all I have is like a
bunch of memories a bunch of dicks I've
sucked
fan says the wall is undefeated all I
can hear from a narcissist is whoa I
need attention yeah uh question do you
guys know what the wall is
it it's a slang in our corner of the
internet
you hit a brick wall no it's it's
basically women around the age of like
27 to 31 where essentially they're not
as hot as they were 10 years ago you you
hit a wall of physical attractiveness
that stops like you know one like let's
I would just argue it if I were to be
nice I would say up to 29 you know
because every girl when she turns 30 she
cries and gets depressed I think you
know so that's what the these like guys
on the internet say like the wall is
when you're like boom I'm just my
physical attractiveness is now at this
point where it's going to start
declining going back and you girls know
that's why you like sometimes you see
these older women and they're like a
young girl around her and the old woman
is like a total to her or whatever
she's salty you see how Pam's laughing
they're like well do I do I have to say
my age yeah
[Laughter]
women women talk about the things
they're proud of yeah like like and so
it's like if she's not proud if she
won't tell you that means she's not
proud of it
yeah yeah yeah so yeah I I totally agree
with you for those women that
unfortunately don't age well in whatever
you would
you would have that mindset yeah that's
what some of these guys say like because
some of these guys don't get sex and so
they're just like well the wall is going
to hit her and it's gonna be vicious or
whatever but it's true and then so what
happens is like these women like this
example we call them post-wall women
all right so these posts while women get
really salty when and then you'll see
this often they'll be like well you know
like for example Al Pacino I think he's
like 82 83. 29 right yeah she's about to
hit the wall and
so she got she she got that baby in you
know she got that baby in but a lot of
guys would you'll see a lot of these
post-wall women
shaming men for wanting younger women
but when she was a younger woman she was
like wait a minute you should go have
sex with this old lady over here no but
it's just it's that female
self-centeredness it's like oh is it not
the consequences of my own decisions
right yeah right like exactly and and
that's the that's the thing nobody feel
feels bad like I just can't even believe
this got an article like oh I got
rejected by men imagine if men came
forward and said I want an article for
getting rejected by women the internet
men don't need articles do they because
the violence against women some people
would argue is evidence of men being
rejected when women are great or essayed
these are the consequences of desirable
women rejecting men who are not
desirable but it doesn't even get to
that level like Sophie was saying
earlier like oh five foot five I don't
even like look those aren't even humans
to me I don't even recognize these
people okay that's a form of that's a
form of rejection
and the other thing we don't we don't
really talk about is that like most
abuse is mutual meaning both parties are
hitting each other so like in when it
comes to one-sided abuse you know
there's some studies that have come out
that say women hit men more than men hit
women they always hit first at least in
my experience yeah
and so like we have this like like we
have this you know image that women are
just the victims and they're never the
aggressive and a lot of times the women
start abuse is very different aren't we
talking cross purposes because abuse is
prolonged and it tends to be quite
intimate right but if I'm talking about
grape an essay it's like if an
attractive woman to walk down the street
tonight
um and she receives advances from a man
and she says that she's not interested
the likelihood of her receiving physical
violent backlash is brought that
rejection for that rejection is very
it's it's high a and it is right it is
high if you look at the nuances it is
contoured it is contoured and it is but
generally speaking no how many women are
raping men on the street the reality
rejection that's not true most abuse
that happens comes from people that you
know not from I'm not talking about
abuse abuse and the things
you're more likely to get gripped by
someone you know
that's absolutely fine and the stats
being we don't dig into because we're
talking about but we're talking about a
very specific thing though aren't we
we're talking about men and women and
the rejections
we're talking about this woman who has
aged and has is post-war and she's no
longer desirable okay fine but I'm
saying that if a man were to like give
advances to a woman and she were to
reject him he is able to and in in many
cases right there are loads of reported
cases of men lashing out at women
sexually violently forced reject this
isn't common though it's not about
whether it's common
if you okay you're painting a whole
picture of men based on something that
happens to a small percentage Yeah like
that's like me saying okay all women are
gold diggers because you know three
percent are go like three percent merry
rich or whatever it is well that's been
a sentiment that has been said on this
podcast right about women wanting men
women tip if you ask women what they
want they typically want men that earn
more that's true and yeah
I'm not trying to go out and rape women
go rape women so that's that's the
problem I haven't said that they are
trying to but it's a consequence of
rejection I mean cases but the analogies
that women typically want richer men but
men typically don't want to go and harm
women they don't but they don't want to
be rejected especially publicly because
that's about male ego we're talking
about female ego with this woman who's
post-war and her ego has led her to like
put all of her stuff on show and we're
saying that no one wants to see that
that's a consequence of her being
rejected did but I'm saying on the other
side of things a consequence of men
being rejected is often violence against
women
what's more common a woman posting a
provocative picture after a breakup or a
man graping a woman
I would say the former yes it's more
it's more common a man graping a woman
no the other four sorry yeah sorry sorry
yeah yeah it is it is definitely more
common but what's more harmful
well clearly the the grape right so
we're talking about the consequences of
rejection and we're saying that nobody
wants to see this woman and all her like
saggy droopy bits whatever but it's like
when men do it it's it's often worse so
you know is it yeah no I would not say
those are the equivalent posting I would
not say the equivalent of a woman
posting a naked selfie online it's the
same as a man raping a woman I'm talking
about the consequence of rejection I I
would not say those are both common
consequences what do men usually do when
they're rejected
um they they usually leave like they
just probably get annoyed and just yeah
find the next one they join the red pill
yeah
they joined the red pill but like I I
just think that you know the majority
guys I I think it's really un like and
it's a and again it's propaganda by the
government well they expand the
definition like even essay like what is
essay that's like everybody now like
everybody's everything's racist well
maybe you if you like eat a lollipop on
the wrong day be like wait that was like
don't eat lollipop day because some guy
died in Chicago you're a racist and it's
just like okay take me out back and
shoot me the Stan says here we go um
with exceptions trying to vilify Men at
Large he's a hundred so he's reading it
um yeah but I just and even the stat
they throw around the one thing that
like one in four women have been great
they expand the definition to include
someone like grabbing your butt at a bar
that's not the no yeah yeah
hmm how did you oh did you
let me grab them like a butthole or
something
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
um guys make sure you like the video
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
what oh sorry I thought someone said
something
um
Rob
um in her Heyday how many men did she
reject at the top of her game
um Kalyn I'm glad to see MLD
collaborating with pearl he's always had
a had a crazy time with him at the fnf 1
million party a great episode Pearl do
you know Kate Kane um I don't know Mr B
um trauma exists and we cannot deny it
however it has become the default path
for people that don't make any effort to
get better we are responsible for the
health and excuses will not be permitted
um you go see a therapist for exercise
to deal with trauma as easy as you can
go see a Grimace Ronald Reagan or the
Hamburglar prescribed 1500 calories
funny doggy um for MLD I've been reading
a study top to bottom it was done with
the medical assistants micronutrients
were injected into this man a long-term
fast requires vitamin and mineral
management
Umi World 204
question for MLD um do you know the
meaning of the first name of your mother
you will get a perspective about an
ideal woman do you know the meaning of
the name of your mother so it's funny
that he mentioned that yeah so savitri
is in known in Indian uh culture her
husband was sent to hell
and savitri went to hell and negotiated
to get her husband out of hell oh wow
yeah so and my mom is like a really good
traditional wife and so like you know
for me she all when she came to Tokyo
she cooked she cleaned she took care of
me and she's like any girl that like
does lifter standard she's like that
girl let's get the out of here
um funny doggy oh and I read this one
Let me refresh it really quick
um
one second also guys make sure you like
the video how crazy is it though that
lady it's like
can you like I'm just thinking if that
was my mother oh scary posting like
naked pictures on Instagram I personally
wouldn't like that oh my God
what are you doing and she's like
talking about what she likes in bed I
think about this when I see the
Kardashian like Kim there's a there's an
article that just came out about a 13
year old boy whose mother has an of and
you saw it yeah you see it's gone
virally I bet you can find it King if
you type in 13 year old boy mother only
and uh
uh like his entire school had like
rallied around abusing him what did he
did he I believe so I think he was 13
years old and he self-deleted because
his mother's only pants well well like
older women are not supposed to move the
same as younger women like you're
supposed to mature and and bullying has
like dude bullying has leveled up like
what these kids are doing now they're
like Hey listen click on this Dropbox
link we've got all your mom's nudes in
there yeah and another kid another kid
too he made a drop box because some of
the girls in the school they would like
send nudes or whatever through chat
snapchat or scent I think it was a it
was Ali recommended the documentary I
think it's called Parenthood 2.0 or
childhood 200 forget what it is but
these kids like one nerd was like
everybody was sending him all the girls
who would send nudes like you know 15 14
16 year olds and he put it on a Dropbox
link and then you could see all of this
stuff it was completely documented I
think it's called Parenthood 2.0 I
complete I I forgot the name of it but
yeah it's getting more in advance like
when we were like bullied as kids like
you know it was like oh third period I
gotta deal with these and I
could go off of my life right you know
their period was over but like now it
literally follows you forever and
someone could say your mom's a hoe but
they couldn't prove it with receipt yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
like we even had the your mama's like
the your mama's so fat jokes do you
remember those
jokes Your mama's so
[Music]
um all great ideas came from the west
side are we gonna say something no sorry
oh sorry I don't know why I think I'm
just hearing things I just keep thinking
I hear someone go
um Phoebe great ideas come from the West
well I do think we're gonna close out
because it is getting pretty late
um thank you guys all for coming I
thought this was a really good
discussion today
um thanks for having us so um now you
guys this is a part of the show where
you can give your final thoughts so any
peace you want to say
um starting here go around in any you
know social media you want to plug go
ahead I don't have anything to pluck but
I will say that my underlying thought on
body positivity is that no we shouldn't
be uh you know celebrating obesity and
poor health but people need to be
encouraged to love the body that they
have while they have it because they're
living in it and it's their one true
home
um and Trauma isn't an excuse there are
no excuses for poor health and your your
life and your poor circumstances may not
be your fault but it's your
responsibility to heal from it and move
on if you can and I was a 80 based for
me yeah
not bad for a first timer not bad for a
first time I'm pretty sure you took all
the words out of my mouth that was
literally yeah um but yeah no agreed 110
you have the right and you have
um what's the word I'm looking for
I don't know what I'm looking for at the
minute
you have the choice to do what you want
with your body but it is also at the end
of the day
how you grow up I feel personally
um
but yeah it's my Instagram do you like
Vegemite I'm obsessive bedroom light oh
sorry who has not had veg here please
put your hands up sounds gross no I'm
sorry my mind that's cheesy to me that
tastes like it does like if you put it
on with butter and you put a little drop
of Mama it actually tastes like cheese
do people eat Vegemite in the UK
go to the shop and I'll go I need my
Vegemite I will go and get my Vegemite
my housemate tasted it okay if you can
do it with a spoon
[Laughter]
yeah I thought it was a really good show
I was actually quite scared to come on
here today yeah I think you're quite
scary are you still
are you scared
no but um I think we covered quite a
good range of subjects today from all
walks of life which is which is
important yeah it was good
uh thank you for having me on today
um it's it's a first time experience
doing a podcast
um and um I think looking back on terms
with the job that I do
um it's important for me to get out
there to love yourself enough to fix the
things that you are not happy with and
to become an even better version of
yourself
um and I don't have Instagram again at
the minute because it's been taken dance
but you can find on Tick Tock and it's
my Wellness Journey
[Applause]
I know I saw it I was just like not
again they're gonna be so happy I'm
kicked off
help you if you need it you have to get
back on it really yeah yeah and that
kind of like starting again
well you don't know if anything does
happen yeah it's like it's kind of like
each account is kind of like an X like
once you're over it you're okay so
so you understand getting closer on a
trauma
[Laughter]
um I had a good time with everybody
thanks everybody for being here um if
you're a man that is struggling with
mental health issues and you know you
need to learn how to cope with the
traumas all that stuff go to Inner
gamehealing.com on June 29th we are
launching a five-day enrollment where
this is an annual long program that's
going to help you have the strategies
put into place to help you overcome your
self-esteem issues it is a men's only
program so ladies are not allowed to
join but we have men experts helping men
and we've been doing this since last
year and you know these are things that
help you get unstuck so inner
gamehealing.com get on the waiting list
thanks so much
foreign
if you struggle with the look of your
body and you're unhappy
it is what it is just know that the way
you look is the way that people have
been seeing your whole life so
this is how you are this is how you look
you can't change that if you don't
stress about getting surgery
if you really want it save up for you
but money is money
all I'm saying is love yourself be body
confident and my Instagram and Tick Tock
is Sugar Puff official
s-u-g-a-p-u-f-f official on Instagram
and Tick Tock thank you very much I
really feel like I saw a softer side of
you and it was actually really beautiful
to see people
[Laughter]
I'll be meaner next time
yeah yeah you're gonna traumatize us it
was so nice it's so nice to have this
little time
sorry go ahead guys it was so nice and I
love the fact that
um as a team everyone bought something
everyone had a story everyone had
experience nobody got kicked off yeah
let's go all right
um I want to give my final thoughts so I
think the most body positive thing you
can do you know is to honestly work on
your health I don't I do think
um a little bit of bullying can be good
for you I I certainly know it was good
for me and anyone that wants to fix that
problem you know I go to training like
what four days a week so you know anyone
who wants to fix it you can just come
with me I'll pay for the training
session
um like the video on your way out um a
couple announcements and thank you
everyone for coming thank you thank you
um a couple announcements before we end
the show guys seriously sign up for the
Google form um it will be in the
comments and in the live chat
also guys
um sign up for the one-on-one call with
me once a month if you want to grow on
YouTube I'm the queen of YouTube I don't
care what anyone says I'm a YouTube
genius
[Music]
145 million in a year and a half you
know top top 1000 YouTube channels in
the United States sign up I'm telling
you I know my also guys
um subscribe to wife school um and let
me know what what I should do next for
wife's school because I've been thinking
about this like the video on your way
out and we'll talk to you next time
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
yo what's going on people King rich is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's Village Johnson Jenny's podcast
it's your boy The Fresh Prince of
someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
if you're saying generation and that
likes the same things that you do go in
there having fun then get out okay okay
then then get out then get out Esther
Esther then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taking care of
taking care of I'm ladylike I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say well I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened in society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag now he's
foreign